there's no time
[Music]
13. o'clock
[Music]
hey everybody hey you got your flock of
Segal shirt I even notice that yeah
I wasn't looking at it it's like you
have a lot of black t-shirts with white
[ __ ] on them so it's like I wasn't so
like that's what it was that's true so
yeah here we are it's Wednesday night
coming to you live from Hurricane Ian
it's just starting to come it's not yeah
I mean we're um I don't know if you guys
know like you know most of us most of
you guys know we're in Florida we are
about
what are like about 25 30 miles north
and slightly west of Orlando like
downtown Orlando it's going to hit us
it's going to hit us but I think we're
not going to get the worst of it I have
been like watching the [ __ ] from like
Naples and uh you know down there like
where it came on land and it's like that
[ __ ] looks [ __ ] up it's all flooded
down there yeah it's uh
it's probably gonna end up being a bunch
of rain in about 70 or 80 mile an hour
winds which is bad but but it's not as
bad as like what they got down there
because man that already looks all
[ __ ] up yeah and we got those houses
are floating away we got about a 50
chance of losing power yeah so usually
it's not for long I just hope it yeah
for a long couple hours I was like I
said I was looking at the ship from
Naples and all I could think was all
those people's houses I'm like oh my God
they're never gonna be able to move back
in those houses now because they're just
like flooded up to the roofs storm surge
man yeah but yeah so hopefully it
doesn't get too bad hopefully we keep
the power it's kind of like it's raining
out and it's kind of windy like every
now and then it gusts really loud but
that's about it but I'm just kind of
hoping that we can at least
yeah granther said Naples is Fubar yeah
everything I saw of it it definitely
looks yeah I got I got word through my
aunt that my dad wanted me to call him
and I called her he goes that thing
gonna hit you it's coming straight for
you and I know you ain't got no supplies
and I know you're gonna build that power
and he's going to go into the whole
thing like what are you talking about no
supplies though it's like all kind of
food we got generators oh oh you do we
gotta go we got gas oh okay all right
yeah he's like that you know does he
still think that you're a child or
something no it's just and like this is
how he is you know I know you [ __ ] it
up
you know thanks Dad yeah that's how bad
it is oh you didn't plan I know it just
hits you you know I know you don't have
any generators he says no I got all I
got two generators oh you do we've had a
couple generators like for a while
because we got they're brand new I mean
we had one before like because we had a
hurricane hit us like a couple years
back and then that second one that I got
could run the old house the entire thing
yeah the entire thing including the
central air system that's how powerful
that one is
it could probably run this but I got two
I got two Central systems but they don't
run at the same time I bet you had run I
bet you'd run them
yeah and I mean like I said we have
um you know we don't have the hook up
though we have window units though so we
can like at least put it in the bedroom
in the office yeah um and use and maybe
we could run like the Wi-Fi and the
freezers in the fridge so we don't lose
all the food and [ __ ] I never got around
installing the hookup in this house well
it's too expensive you all didn't give
me enough super chats
I tried to guilt everything yeah yeah
yeah yeah because it would have cost
like two grand to get the hookups well I
I do to do both generators so I'd have
two of them bad boys two of them bad
boys running out well it's no use of
like crying about it now it's too late
now that's right and then I'd [ __ ]
try to build a damn iron cage around
them so no one could steal them when
[ __ ] bulletproof glass and electric
eyes and proximity dragons sitting on
track of it and [ __ ] when you get close
to my [ __ ] generators it [ __ ]
beats my cell phone or run down there
with an AR and light your [ __ ] ass up
[ __ ] peeing on my goddamn property in
a damn state of emergency seeing [ __ ]
just bury you out in the backyard
all the neighbors watching who do you
shoot you're [ __ ] funny
Ben says front page story this morning
was how this hurricane will be the worst
ever and depopulate Florida yeah it's
like uh well I mean all the people that
moved down here are probably like oh
yeah yes this kind of sucks a lot of
that's hate you know what I mean they
want to see us get hit real bad because
they don't like our governor nobody said
that I didn't yeah oh Florida's gone oh
Florida's gonna be [ __ ] well the thing
about it cool Florida is gonna be [ __ ]
up but the thing about it is that well
it always happens not here but yeah it's
like I mean this is the worst one that's
hit here for probably like 30 40 years
yeah I don't remember one
where it's hitting the where it's
hitting is uh probably gonna be okay
though it's it's a lot worse if it hits
the very tip
my understanding it's easier to flood
there we'll see well it's like I said
Naples is already flooded yeah I already
saw this [ __ ] because you know that's
just gonna happen though well yeah but
I'm just saying it's not good though I'm
like that was your house but the thing
about it the budget if you're gonna move
to Florida I I would not advise buying a
house if you could afford it I would not
advise buying a house on actually I
would not advise I would not advise like
moving to Florida anyway but I'm just I
would not advise like buying anything on
the coast because eventually your
number's gonna come up your number's
gonna come up eventually well I wouldn't
I would never say don't move to Florida
mood Florida if you want to move to
Florida well yeah it does I'm making a
joke what the rules are I'm just saying
yeah that it's like if you're not real
into because this happens every year we
don't get a bad one like this every year
yeah like this is the worst one in the
world I've been prepping and [ __ ] and I
got all prepping survival stuff it's not
all just because of apocalypse
this is the [ __ ] golf this is the
gulf all right it's not just Florida
Mississippi too Louisiana Alabama
Panhandle you're going to get hit by
hurricanes that's just how it is
you know every uh my whole time living
down here
well I lived here my whole life so yeah
[ __ ] annihilated by Katrina
you know good I wasn't there at the time
Pass Christian Gulfport Biloxi got hit
[ __ ] hard [ __ ] them up but they
came right back
I mean it takes a while yeah the worst
one I remember in Florida that I
remember like I wasn't there but it was
Andrew but that was Miami and yeah down
there New Orleans got it got it much
worse than [ __ ] Gulf Gulf to coast of
Mississippi during Katrina but
the [ __ ] the rest of the coast got
[ __ ] up too
went as bad as Katrina I mean you had
what was he wasn't as bad as New Orleans
a lot of people ran from New Orleans and
went to Gulfport and Biloxi for safety
even though it was [ __ ] up there too
just not as [ __ ] up as
New Orleans New Orleans is in a damn
Bowl
it's just floods it floods that's what
it does
and you know I don't mean to be brutal
but if you live in New Orleans you're
you've signed on
you're going to get flooded well I mean
it's not you should know and it's the
same thing about moving to floor I mean
I know that some people were like me or
like born here and you're kind of like
stuck there like you can't afford to
move or whatever but it's just kind of
like Florida too all of Florida I don't
know if you guys know this all of
Florida is right at sea level we don't
have any Hills or nothing like that so
like if you know [ __ ] goes up the whole
[ __ ] State's going underwater pretty
much yeah now
I you know I was there I was there for
Katrina I was up in Baton Rouge area
it was [ __ ] bad real bad I was in
support for [ __ ] State Police keeping
them [ __ ] running during all that
[ __ ] emergency
[ __ ] man it was in him and the cops were
just walking off the job like [ __ ]
crying and [ __ ] couldn't take it
all the weird [ __ ] that was happening
watching people just get wiped out
[ __ ] buildings filled with [ __ ]
dead old people and stuff you know well
that's what I'm kind of worried about
too because then like they were talking
about it like on some of the news things
that I was watching they said you know a
lot of the people well a lot of people
live in South Florida are like old
people yeah and they can't really can't
run from it evacuate because they did
tell everybody to evacuate but obviously
there's gonna be people yeah everybody
starts running the cops start running
everybody's running it's just the
[ __ ] it's like The Walking Dead and
it's just and if you're if you're in
firm or old or dumb you're left behind
and you die
just just
but that's it you know I mean now some
people say well could you know New
Orleans shouldn't have been hit because
of the the levees and [ __ ] the levees
broke
just like that Led Zeppelin yeah the
levees broke but the thing is is that if
you signed on to New Orleans you know
that those levees [ __ ] suck anyway
all right [ __ ] was [ __ ] built by
contractors [ __ ] the lowest [ __ ]
bidding [ __ ] contractor it's always
it was held to get New Orleans for
hundreds of years New Orleans was held
to get together with spit tape and
baling wire it was just made up as it
went the [ __ ] was built on [ __ ]
cotton bales
and then the cotton Bales all rotted you
know a lot of people don't know that but
that's how they [ __ ] filled that damn
swap to build the areas it got bigger
cotton bales
well like I said that's the thing about
Florida too is that a lot of Florida
before they started developing it was a
swamp and probably should have stayed a
swamp to be honest with you because it's
like it's a constant kind of constant
struggle of [ __ ] where where we used to
live over in Sanford every time it
didn't have to be a hurricane it was
just like a regular everyday like uh
summer storm you'd walk up The Path and
like people's yards be totally flooded
and it would and it would be flooded for
like days and days and days where we
live right now it looks like a golf
course with a bunch of nice houses and
stuff and then around it a bunch of
cattle farms and cattle ranches and
horse ranches it's it's pretty here
hopefully a little couches yeah but if
you just go
three or four mile uh six miles up this
road you'll go over a bridge and if you
look to the right it looks like the
Amazon [ __ ] Basin it looks like the
[ __ ] Amazon jungle and that's what
it's just a weird mix and it's all
happening and all in one spot
it just looks you'll see
it looks like you're in [ __ ] Nebraska
and two seconds later it looks like
you're in dagopa
that's how quickly it changes
yeah like I said it's a big [ __ ] swap
yeah swaps Florida is a swamp pretty
much
it's swamp Beach that's about it yeah
and then and then try to build stuff
over in Disney used to be as well too
yeah that's just they just like piled
some dirt on it and then built theme
park Disney is Dagobah they just masked
over it if you look outside Disney you
go God damn yeah it looks like something
out of damn Pirates of Caribbean ride
yeah it does and it smells like that
yeah uh Danny Rowling said what's your
favorite MRE meal to eat
oh well I only had the old ones a lot of
the new ones I've never had like they
got Taco in there and pizza and [ __ ]
I've never had any of that well what's
your favorite out of the older the old
ones
barbecue pork and rice really that was
good they don't have that anymore I
think they're all Halal now all right
back in the day they didn't play that
your bit your ass was eating pork all
right it was a [ __ ] back in those
days the [ __ ] the the United States
Army was a southern Army it was all
[ __ ] rednecks and [ __ ] rednecks and
[ __ ] Southern blacks and whites with
some Hispanics okay and Island Boys yeah
the guys from [ __ ] Guam and
Hawaii and Micronesia and [ __ ]
Polynesian [ __ ] all they were in
there too and they everybody ate pork
[ __ ] it is a pork loving Army
but so I like that barbecue pork was
good with rice probably can't get it
anymore
um
ham slice was real good because it was
just a block of [ __ ] ham and bride
I liked the Omelette most people didn't
like it but I like The Omelette it was a
brick of cooked eggs with uh something
in there
ham or sausage I don't remember yeah
mystery meat
um
I like them all man I did I liked them
all and everybody was talking bad about
chicken all the king
I'd [ __ ] get I'd have a whole [ __ ]
rucksack full of chicken all the king I
liked it nobody else liked it but I
would cook with it you know mix your
crackers in there and your [ __ ] hot
sauce and because each of those little
things came a little bitty Tabasco glass
Tabasco [ __ ] bottles and [ __ ] we had
classy MREs back in the day
that was back before the MRE heater we
had those two later on we added the
water they kind of sucked we would cook
that [ __ ] with a heat tab man over a
[ __ ]
um canteen cup in a Cantina cup
which went around your canteen it was
metal had handles on it you put it make
a little hole and put a little we had a
little Canty cup [ __ ] holder it would
slip around there and you could put it
upside down put a heat tab in there it
was like dried Sterno
and you could catch it on fire and
[ __ ] put it in there I got a bunch of
those I like the old school [ __ ] it was
it's better than the high-tech [ __ ]
that [ __ ] went on let me tell you
[ __ ] something as the as the US Army
evolved it got more and more [ __ ] uh
the uh the the operations became more
and more law enforcement like and they
were all kind of most of them were
deploying from Vehicles so the equipment
that they gave them was less and less
and less field survival and more and
more cop-like so they lost out on a lot
of stuff they had to open up new schools
like jungle warfare and [ __ ] like that
lrsd schools to teach dudes how to be a
[ __ ] Soldier and live off land and
[ __ ] be out for [ __ ] 70 days with
a rucksack and [ __ ] just surviving
you know most of them didn't do that
because the nature of the war changed
and the nature of the equipment that
they gave him was
started to be oriented around vehicles
not just walking around Mad Max style
living you know like Conan
Mr 88 said Miss chaps for the past month
have been watching after the fact you
may not have missed me but I missed you
well of course we always miss you guys
when you don't show up actually a lot of
the people we still miss you we miss
Tila We Miss Sandra the peanut butter
girl yeah we don't know what happened to
her they got killed they've shut up no
they didn't have to they got killed
that's nice you're so you're so like
cool to hang out with Tom you're like
always so positive San Francisco is a
high mortality rate there Sandra's in
Germany sure she's fine Saunders in
Germany they're freezing to get death
they don't have sure they don't have any
oil or anything I'm sure they're fine
we'll see Tom I'm sure let's see what
they can have to speak up I'm sure that
it's just something like oh I don't I
got a new job and I don't have time to
like it so it's almost always something
mundane you know what I mean all those
times they got killed yeah great are you
gonna be in one of those kind of moods
tonight because that's because this is
come on Trent well yeah yeah great it's
gonna be all right
so yeah
yeah topic that has nothing to do with
either the hurricane or the topic of
tonight's show I was wondering what else
is new it's all good uh just waiting for
everybody to show up actually it's we
can start Mr uh Mr 88 said Florida's low
yeah it is if the sea level rises just
two or three inches something like 75 of
Florida will be underwater yep that's
right that's right to my my home uh my
hometown of Daytona Beach would uh be
underwater yes it would
no big loss I'm not getting it out it
would take a while I got I got like
family that went there I'm just it would
take a long time for that to happen you
see the water coming over it happened
over [ __ ] Generations you just walk
out of here like it always does this is
Evan's already party said where is that
I can where is that
there it is right there right there
that's right I
have that I went to all the trouble to
make that and then like I forgot that I
had it because it's right there like in
My Little like video thingy yep but yeah
so I'm just saying the the weather seems
to be holding up right now but
you know if you're arriving late we are
in Florida uh hurricane Ian is about
three or four hours south of here so if
the power goes out you'll know what
happened but I think it's okay for now I
think it's okay for now Mrs Evans
already said [ __ ] yes but yeah so uh oh
before we get too much into it I wanted
to do a couple of thank yous I think I
already thanked um Dermot who is uh one
of our friends of the show and one of
our patrons from the UK and he sent me a
very generous uh PayPal donation for my
birthday so thank you very much Dermot
also I want to thank uh Miguel who also
gave me a uh a very nice donation or
birthday present like uh so thank you
very much thank you guys very much also
Esther who is a friend of the show and
uh one of our patrons actually sent me a
message on patreon and was you know uh
saying she was gonna send us some movies
and posters and stuff and she's like
she's gonna wait till the storm passes
okay just because yeah they're I mean
they're kind of closing stuff up and we
got mail today but I don't know about
tomorrow no I probably won't get it
tomorrow because I know that Amazon is
like closing some of their warehouses
and stuff around here so I don't know if
we're gonna like get any stuff but [ __ ]
but she like gave me her uh phone number
and stuff like that and said hey if you
guys need anything like our new frames
man for these lenses I can pop them out
and change them [ __ ] I've been
wearing [ __ ] glasses that has one
side to it for [ __ ] a week
still waiting on my [ __ ] to show up
what do you want me to do about it once
you get out there and speed that mail up
for me
I'll get right on that you just hold
your breath and wait
that's all times because my
Christmas bro you seriously don't have
another pair no I don't no they're broke
too
down to my list keep breaking them
I've had this pair and another pair of
reading glasses for like for a couple of
years
well I had those for a couple years too
and it's like I didn't break them
actually I didn't break the other ones I
just lost them I think I left them at
the um at the club one night because
they fell out of my purse that's Army
birth control glasses
yeah burnt control yeah okay I control
bird every time I put these things on
how about Ernie yeah
and I hadn't had any children since they
gave these [ __ ] things to me so
they're working
that's good can't get laid in that [ __ ]
that's right yeah [ __ ] VA VA gave
them to me man
I like those glasses actually they'll
look like that dude off of [ __ ] uh
off that [ __ ]
sicario movie
you know what I'm talking about yeah
well I know I got one side
[Laughter]
my dad would make a comment over some
[ __ ] like that why you only got one side
on everything
he did he said well you'd be like wow
you're real observant yeah let me see
that you only got one side on there
yeah thanks for stating it obvious you
did you knew then yeah I knew you know
that [ __ ] I know it's like I love that
the way they're telling you like they
like you don't know I'm like it's
they're sitting on my face yeah it's
like I'm pretty well aware it was that
generation
[Laughter]
that what they think everyone else is an
idiot yeah yeah I don't know what it is
I guess it's just you're giving them an
opportunity to say something well maybe
that's what it is because he did like
when you called him yesterday yeah and
he said I bet you don't have anything
for the hurricane even though we have
all the [ __ ] yeah hurricane yeah I got
candles like a flashlight so we got
everything yeah I know you're [ __ ] up
you know that's the attitude yeah they I
kind of feel like that generation thinks
everyone younger than them is stupid
yeah
especially if you're their children
that's what I'm saying and like I was
talking about like my mom doesn't like
my mom is awesome and she uh is not like
that at all but she is kind of like well
she's like that's the thing I mean and
my mom is like 68 like I think she just
turned 68 but she's like even like as
old as your kids get you still think of
them as your babies like as your kids so
it's really hard for them to pop into
another mindset that this is like
another adult that can do the same adult
[ __ ] that you can do yeah so they do
come kind of come across like that like
your parents yeah well he's [ __ ]
you're not calling me that thing coming
straight towards you
I mean not sees you you know it's easy
it's coming right for you yes it sees
you
that's awesome yeah I'm gonna have to go
down and see him soon he ain't gonna
make it much longer he's not he's not
doing good yeah he was talking about he
told me yeah you better come down and
see me before I die I'm sick of this
it's gonna be basically what he said
it's not gonna make it much longer yeah
because he well you talked to him a long
time on the phone yesterday and then you
came in back in and said hey like after
the beginning of the month I might like
I might have to go down and reveal out
there and visit him because yeah right
up here on a bike it's only six it's
only about eight hours yeah I think it's
like about an eight hour drive yeah all
right up there man yeah it looks like
it's a lot cheaper than the [ __ ]
flying I'm sure well then I gotta rent a
car
I hate that [ __ ] I like to do my [ __ ] on
my own you know yeah I get that I'll buy
you too I'll buy a saddle bag kit for
that [ __ ] bill
a couple hundred bucks I mean it only
take a day it would only take a day not
even yeah like not even a day it's not
that's that's a work shift and I would
[ __ ] stop halfway get something to
eat yeah that's almost like four hour
and four hours as long as the weather
was was okay like it wasn't raining or
nothing like I got equipment for all
that I don't give a [ __ ] about wet
weather yeah I'm just saying it's not
like I got to be there by any amount of
time I would just take my time right
that's what I'm saying it'd be much
easier because like I said the dumb ass
thing is like even if you flew there I
mean I think the flight's only like it
maybe not even an hour but by the time
you get to the airport
it'd probably take the same amount of
time and it would cost like [ __ ]
three or four times as much so yeah and
then if I was you I would do all that
car rental [ __ ] yeah and then I
would have to fly in to somewhere in New
Orleans in the New Orleans area
so I had to [ __ ] drive [ __ ] three
hours anyway
that's what I'm saying so you might as
well just [ __ ] you know do it
independently just ride down there
painting paper for the gas I get [ __ ]
almost 60 miles to gallon maybe 55 60
miles a gallon on the on the xb9 but I
could take the 12 too get mileage is
about the same might be even better
because I can lower that RPM on the 1203
and just Cruise
yeah I mean as long as you're careful
it's like you know you just go down
there you should probably go down there
and see him at some point because it's
been
well last time you went to see him was
when he had the heart bypass yeah and
when was that two years ago three years
ago more yeah about three years I think
it was three years he's lasted longer
than I thought he was gonna last
actually I didn't think he was really
going to make it through that whole
[ __ ] bypass thing I mean from I died
a couple times that's what I mean it's
like I didn't go but like the way you
described it because you were out there
for what two weeks [ __ ] shocked him
back alive when he was already cut open
I was surprised too I think that was
three years ago yeah pretty sure that
was three years ago
uh he complained the whole time
why am I here
[Laughter]
exactly like that when you're the old
time well you're already kind of like
yeah I'll crotchety you told his friend
his friend Sonny was there and sorry go
to record my truck get my gun we're
getting out of here
and he meant he's gonna bust this way
yeah he was his truck wasn't with him
and Sonny knows he's [ __ ]
hallucinating
he thought he had been abducted by a
cult
he knew he was in a hospital he didn't
believe it oh my God yeah he thought he
got it Samantha said uh who are you
talking about Tom's dad yeah yeah Tom
senior he thought he thought he got
abducted by a cult when they put him on
they were doing experiments he had a
heart bypass yeah a couple years two or
three years ago and Tom went out to see
him I'd leave and come back in like in a
recovery room
and start talking to him and realized
and I was slowly realized that he didn't
know who I was yeah that well that's par
for the course yeah he didn't know who I
was and I said you know you know I'm
your son right oh yeah yeah that's right
I do have one of those you forget where
he was by the way I'm full of turkey
necks
I thought they put him back together
with turkey necks oh dear Poor Dad you
should probably go visit him though like
I said like maybe after the first of the
month like after payday or whatever
that's because his should go out his
neighbor who takes care of him Clarice
she's uh this
she's just she's a good looking
um black woman who's his neighbor who's
the wife of a black dude who is he's
National Guard sergeant major
and they they watch out over my dad real
well she checks on him [ __ ] every day
and [ __ ] [ __ ] you know I got him on
Facebook I'm thanking them all the time
for them staying on top of him
and uh
she came and visited him in the hospital
and then went back and he remembered
that well one of the things that she
would give him all the time is [ __ ]
turkey necks like his dish it whenever
she was making turkey necks she'd give
himself
as a Mississippi Food you know
because she he saw her he made that
turkey neck connection and he thought
that the doctors had reassembled his
Hearts using turkey neck parts
because I saw them put Dougie next in
and said no dad no no I mean maybe I saw
it he's just [ __ ] gone crazy he had
[ __ ] Hospital psychosis and [ __ ]
the drugs and [ __ ]
what happens yeah I mean they're used to
it
he had a [ __ ] Out of Body Experience
he wasn't in there partially he was
trying to escape
losing his [ __ ] mind yeah all in a
couple days period
uh Zach says Hey Y'all how's the storm
going we kind of covered that a little
bit at the beginning but it's still a
few hours like south of us
um we're probably gonna get the worst
that we're gonna get maybe I kind of
feel like early this morning you know
what I mean yeah like every like it's
raining outside a little bit and we
still get like we get Gus every now and
then but we're not getting the worst of
it I think until because it's supposed
to be the eye is supposed to be over
Orlando at what like tomorrow morning at
eight and we're about 30 miles north of
Orlando
downtown Orlando so we'll see you know
what sucks is my my poor sister she's
coming down to Disney
on Saturday so I'm kind of hoping that
everything because Disney's closed today
and tomorrow
um but I'm kind of hoping that her
vacation isn't ruined too because she
paid a lot of money for that but I think
Disney will have all their [ __ ] together
by the time Sunday because I'm supposed
to go on Sunday and like uh see her
turkey neck soup and never heard of just
eating them yeah yeah just eat them man
uh she slow Cooks them and then they're
kind of fried
so it's kind of like eating fried
chicken
on the bow it's like that
but you can get a lots of them for next
to nothing in Mississippi so you can
turn
40 dollars into enough to feed like
[ __ ] 10 people
you know she got a big family of kids
and stuff and she you know it's a
Mississippi thing it's food is like a a
religion that's why everyone decide yeah
you share a lot of food happen to my
family too yeah yeah
and why aren't you eating yeah have a
third helping come on it's are you sick
and in the South it's just called food
in the north they call it soul food but
black people white people eat the same
food in the South pretty much it just
the only difference is family recipes
so it's just that's what that's what the
traditional foods are you know and
Clarice is like Clarice is real cute
she's good looking woman and uh my dad
loves her you know he you know I could
and his friends like her you know and
these are all old guys and Clarice is
like
43 44 maybe you know she's younger than
Jenny probably so
he remembers seeing her you know what I
mean I guess he thinks about he's
probably got a crush on her probably you
know but she's married you know but she
feeds him so he's
he loves her you know that's what it is
Clarice
Zach says it's actually perfect you guys
are doing this topic because I've been
watching a ton of videos Lately by a guy
who's a fine art restorer yeah I'm
fascinated by that kind of stuff this
guy I've been wanting to do a show about
this guy forever and it's just kind of
like I was so happy because I put him in
the patreon poll like a bunch of times
and it never wins but this time it like
won overwhelmingly I'm like finally like
I get to this because I read a book
about this dude like a long time ago and
he's like fascinating I don't know why
like art forgery is like really
fascinating to me but I guess that's
what it is because I'm kind of into art
anyway but I don't know I'm just
fascinated by Art forgers
um let's see
uh Zach also said I meant what I said
about doing a show on Queen Victoria
that woman was fascinating yeah we
probably should
Ben said you need to visit your Dad more
often yeah well and Zach said I'd still
kill to see Tom's dad on the show or
something I want to hear his voice for
real [ __ ] man that's pretty much you
don't want to see him he's only 130
pounds now yeah he's down to nothing my
phone's ringing cancer got him cancer
and all kinds of other stuff got him too
that's why maybe in a week or two you
should probably yeah and they're telling
him he needs to go on chemo and he's
like [ __ ] that [ __ ] just let me die he's
what he's doing now like that he's he's
getting pissed off my grandmother yeah
because he doesn't feel good yeah
he says I can't do nothing anyway it's
time for me to go
it's his choice
well yeah that's what I mean like I said
this is my grandfather my grandmother
did the same thing she kind of went
through the surgery and stuff and they
were like well we didn't get it all like
we have to do chemo and she was like
yeah he he's he's saying why the hell
should I fight and Claw for every every
minute of life and all I'm gonna do sit
here watch television I can't do nothing
it sucks because I don't feel good
so I don't blame it
I don't either so this shit's over
yeah
but like I said probably
after the first of the month you should
probably go see him yeah I'm gonna try
right up here see him you know I mean
just money works out then uh it should
work out yeah I mean it shouldn't be
that expensive to go out there like
depending because you can see you can
stay in his house right what are some
yeah but there's some stuff I Gotta Buy
but it would still be cheaper than the
plane ticket than a plane ticket yeah
yeah
um let's see Ben says people like
hearing about art forgery because it's
essentially a story of experts being
made fools of by often uneducated people
yeah yeah in this case it's the Nazis
the Nazis didn't know what the [ __ ] they
were doing either a lot of time well the
thing this is like a really interesting
story because yeah there's a lot of like
really interesting angles to this and
the thing about
um and I'm sure if anyone is Dutch I'm
sure I'm gonna like pronounce because
this is like the guy's Dutch and he like
grew up in the Netherlands so I'm just
kind of like I'm just warning you ahead
of time that probably all of the Dutch
names I'm going to mispronounce horribly
so I apologize for that but he wasn't
um he actually wasn't all that
uneducated he the thing that I find
interesting about art forgery is that
it's illegal like it's a criminal
Enterprise but you can't just be
half-assed about it you gotta commit you
gotta go all in this dude spent years
and years and years trying to figure out
how to like Forge these so he could get
away with it you know what I mean so
it's almost kind of you almost kind of
want to let him get away with it because
well he put so much work into it you
know what I mean yeah but what's
interesting about this guy too I mean
there's a lot of interesting things
about him too was that
um one I kind of feel like his forgeries
at first were not great but there was
kind of like some other factors that
made people like be like oh my God it's
a real you know
but even though they weren't really that
fantastic
um and then like the quality of them got
shittier and shittier and you know he
got away with it for a long time and he
made a [ __ ] ton of money before he got
caught and the way that he got caught
was really kind of interesting so I
first heard about this guy when I was a
kid and I had this book called strange
stories amazing facts which was one of
those big like Readers Digest
compilation books I still have it
and I remember
uh the name of the article about this
guy was called he paints for his life um
and it kind of paints a picture of him
because the interesting thing about this
guy is that he kind of has a popular
there's a popular notion about him it's
like oh you know he fooled the Nazis and
everything and I kind of put that in the
like on the thumbnail and everything
like that because I kind of feel like
that's the popular conception of him and
I don't know yes it's technically true
but I don't think it was almost kind of
like incidental that that happened
you know what I mean which we'll get
into it's just like a really really
interesting story
uh Mr 88 said quality art forgery is an
art in itself like stealth bank robbery
yeah I think that's what it is I kind of
admire like I don't admire that they're
breaking the law but you have to admire
like there's much easier ways to break
the law if if that's your inclination
but if you go into like these high-end
bank robberies or like art forgery or
something like that like I said that
takes commitment you can't just
half-assed you can't just half-ass art
forgery you have to know what you're
doing
um because you will get caught
immediately if you don't yeah you'll get
caught immediately this dude like I said
this dude spent years and years and
years perfecting
the [ __ ] you can't uh you can't half-ass
making counterfeit bills either is it
yeah exactly exactly cut whole plates
and they'd probably make a damn
counterfeit so I admire that I admire
like the the technique and the art that
goes into it
um and it's just kind of a shame that
they were obviously like really talented
but used it for a nefarious purpose but
I don't know like art forgery I kind of
feel I don't want to say it's a
victimless crime because it's not but
art forgery is almost kind of like stuff
you can kind of like be okay with it
it's like no one's necessarily gonna get
murdered over the [ __ ] or anything like
that so
I don't know it's just I don't feel too
bad about it so it's like a con game
yeah that's what I mean I don't I don't
think anybody should get conned that's
not cool but
I don't know I I can't get too mad at it
yeah you know what I mean like it's just
on the spectrum of crime it's one that
makes me the least mad that one and kind
of like like I said bank robberies you
know as long as you don't hurt anybody
or threaten anybody or anything like
that but one of the another thing that I
wanted to do a show about
that I kept putting in the uh patreon
poll but hasn't won yet is the Antwerp
uh Diamond Heist because that was
another thing that I was like a whole
team and they took like two or three
years and they had a mole on the inside
and it was just kind of like I mean the
[ __ ] the links that they went to I was
almost kind of like man just let them
have it yeah if they're gonna do all
that holy [ __ ] I don't now I don't
really know how Jenny's gonna structure
this show I haven't seen the seen her
notes
but this is most a lot of this is going
to have to do with a guy who's basically
scamming dudes out third right
well he scammed one dude out of the
third oh he scammed others so it's not
all of them because there was a bunch of
art theft that went on with the third
right too
and uh if we're not gonna take it from
that angle then I don't know exactly
what I'm gonna maybe I shouldn't even
talk about it
um well it's relevant I mean the thing
about it it is kind of relevant we'll
get into that in a little bit thing
about think about the dude the the uh
the dudes in the Third Reich especially
the the the the upper command
they were basically coming out of a dam
kind of like a revolutions slash Civil
War
they were working class and middle class
dudes that really didn't come from money
and then all of a sudden they make it
they make it big they're now in charge
of Germany
and they they're trying to pick up upper
class and Upper Crust tastes but they
don't [ __ ] have
they don't really have the background
for it
so it was kind of easy to fool them with
with Fakes and it was easy to fool them
with
you could con them into buying [ __ ]
it was funny like okay there's a lot of
witnesses that would say that
not only mustache man but a lot of the
other high [ __ ] level [ __ ] Nazis
would do [ __ ] like hire contractors to
renovate [ __ ] these castles and the
[ __ ] Decor was horrendous all right
and it was just it was not the kind of
Decor that
an upper class German would put in there
it was the kind of Decor that would go
with that a working-class German would
put in there trying to emulate upper
class tastes but you could see that it
wasn't that they weren't really
you know that they didn't really have
good taste in things even though they
wanted people to respect them you know
so
because a lot of them had that not all
of them but most of them had a
background like that they were ripe for
buying [ __ ] like fake art and [ __ ]
fake knockoff [ __ ] decor and [ __ ]
well because they were if they were
almost like really graspingly desperate
to be seen as someone that was like
upper class that somebody that had like
really good taste tasted [ __ ] but that's
not how they really were but yeah but
that's kind of a hard thing to fake
really and people who are actually upper
class or who are from old money or like
have actually they do it effortlessly
yeah because they grew up in that whole
milieu and they don't like need to put
it on for anybody it's not a put on it's
just how they are right these those guys
had to put it on
because look man mustache man was
homeless slept underneath the bridge
he was a Corporal in World War one he
was a
you know not saying he was a total
nobody it's just that he didn't have
money
he didn't come from money
his dad was [ __ ] working class maybe
lower middle class he was a [ __ ]
official he worked at some
licensing office or post office I don't
remember exactly what it was but Alois
was his name and then a lot of the other
guys who really wasn't much to him you
know Goring was uh he was probably one
of the higher class ones he was an
officer in World War one and a dab World
War One fighter Ace I mean they kind of
recruited him just to give them some
Mojo you know to make them seem more
official
but he was also kind of you know
morphine addict and um he had a lot of
stolen art which is actually it was
actually Goring that uh got [ __ ] over
is he the one okay yeah he would [ __ ]
dress up in a toga and [ __ ] have all
this [ __ ] art around him and he
you know larped as a damn Roman [ __ ]
emperor when people people weren't
around you know but okay it was Goring
that was buying it yeah yeah I
understand that but Goring really his he
was middle class
middle class maybe maybe upper middle
class
so that's funny that he was the one that
fell for it but he also had a lot of
real art too uh stolen well yeah stolen
yeah we'll get into that like yeah uh
Hugo said remember that guy that made
the coffin of James brother of Jesus he
replicated a 2000 year old uh patinas
and people believed him he almost got
away with it I remember hearing about
that they made a documentary about that
[ __ ] like if it was real it wasn't real
but yeah so like I said I do kind of
admire like I said I don't really admire
people that con other people have money
but the thing about art forgery is that
usually the people that they're conning
have a [ __ ] ton of money so I can't feel
too bad about it and like I said you
kind of have to admire the art that they
put into it because like I said you
can't just like slap some [ __ ] on a
[ __ ] canvas and be like hey look it's
a what it's a Rembrandt you know what I
mean it's like No One's Gonna Fall for
that I I saw one program though that
talked about the art forgery angle and
sometimes they said that the dude
buying the art forgery
didn't care if it was forged or not it
just had to be a good enough forgery to
fool his friends that that was what yeah
which yeah that's another thing himself
then he's just like well it's worth it
to me to drop however many million
dollars it's like yeah it could be a
fake but it doesn't yeah I don't care
right it doesn't matter so a lot of
there was a lot of that in the art
forgery stuff too
yeah they're like well that'll fool my
friends even if it's a forgery I don't
give a [ __ ]
yeah as long as they kind of as long as
they believe it right Ben says the
customers are usually dishonest in some
way too they generally believe they're
buying stolen art at the least yeah so
there's that too yeah so like I said
it's not you know it's still a crime but
it's kind of one that I don't really
feel too bad about but like I said Han
van meegrine have always like and I'm
like I said I'm sure I'm pronouncing
that wrong
but he's always kind of been a
fascinating figure to me he's not
I kind of feel like like I said the
popular kind of portrayal of him is kind
of like oh he's the hero that like
pulled the wall over the eyes of the
Nazis that's not exactly right um things
are always kind of like a lot more
complicated than that uh but we'll get
into that in a little bit but he's still
like a fascinating dude anyway so are we
ready to get into this go ahead and do
it yeah Ben said famous religious fraud
I've actually been wanting to do a show
I should probably write this down I
thought I had it in my list but maybe I
don't I've actually been wanting to do a
show about like fake religious relics
because there's a lot of that so because
there's a whole that's a whole other
market like I read a whole bunch of
books about that and it's like really
really interesting let me go ahead and
give you another drawing here okay
because I always like I don't know I'm
always like really interested I don't
know why I'm so fascinated by like art
forgery and Architectural or uh not
architectural what am I talking about
um what's the word oh my God it just
went right in my head it also starts
with an A
archaeological Jesus Christ what the
[ __ ] is the matter with me I'm like not
even drunk
[Laughter]
this guy looks like a fake ass Ian
McKellen he does a little bit
the only Dutch name he didn't know is
Edward Van Halen
uh I was watching another video about
this guy earlier and uh the guy that's
on there he's a really cool like he has
like a million channels um what's his
name Simon Whistler like he's a British
guy and he does like he's one called
biographics and uh today I learned and
stuff like that so he did a show about
this guy and he was trying to like
pronounce the stuff right but he was
just kind of at the end he was just like
[ __ ] it I'm not Dutch sorry I'm just
gonna pronounce it the way it looks so
I'm like yeah that's probably what I'm
gonna do too because I'm just like I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna do it and plus I
feel like really pretentious when I try
to
pronounce things the way they're awesome
it is very good no you haven't had it
yet oh I haven't that was regular vodka
oh that was the end of the Bacardi no
that will now try it
pineapple yeah it's really good
oh that's that new brand that we bought
yeah
Samantha said that's age yeah because I
said architectural when I was trying to
think of archaeological yeah well
because well in my defense the word
architecture is right there like in
front of my face like on my notes so
yeah the way just go on the the
hurricane will arrive it will arrive on
State on stage part way I mean it'll be
blowing out there in about an hour or
two maybe we'll see yeah I'm kind of
it's kind of quiet out there now but
we'll see if I looked at that back
window I could see it uh-oh can you can
you see like the the bands no I can see
the wind blowing oh
yeah Mr 88 said if you're going to do a
show on fake religious documents you
should focus on the Mormons I've
actually
a whole show white salamander letters
and all that uh yeah I want to do a
whole show on the Mormons actually
that's right they have an entire
organization that buys and or fake
documents that uh contradict their
gospel yet that's right they do I saw a
documentary about that not too long ago
so yeah the Mormons would need their
whole own show
and I think I think that's on my list
but I'm gonna write it down again just
in case because the Mormons will buy a
fake even though even if they know it's
a fake just they just don't want it
around well that's what he's saying that
it's like they're trying to like take
stuff out of circulation all right so uh
so let's get into this before like I
said I don't want like the hurricane to
hit and like [ __ ] knock the power out
or nothing like that
um Oscar says watch Barbarian while it's
still in theaters honestly every single
person except one person has told me
that Barbarian is awesome and that we
should go see it I get I did get one
message from somebody that said it was
terrible
but and don't bother with it but
everybody else that I've seen has said
it was like really really good so
I'll probably I probably won't see it
like I said I've seen like a lot of Buzz
about it
but yeah we'll we'll see that
all right so we're talking today about
Han van meegerin like I said I'm sure
I'm pronouncing that wrong I'm not Dutch
my stupid phone is [ __ ] just yeah
it's just warnings from the store no
it's um it's telemarketers oh I get
[ __ ] zillions of [ __ ] telemarketer
shows like uh calls all the time every
day
and I thought I turned the thing off but
it's just like making a
irritating noise
so yeah so like I said known as a
painter and portraitist one of the most
ingenious art forgers of the 20th
century now as I said he's kind of like
perceived as a or became perceived as a
national hero after World War II because
of the whole story about how he uh
he didn't necessarily sell it to the
Nazis he's traded it but we'll get into
that
in a little bit too uh to uh Goring and
so after that they were like hey yeah he
[ __ ] over the Nazis and stuff like
that but like I said it's not exactly
how it happened and like there's a lot
more complication to it than that but
we'll get into that
okay so he was born in 1889.
um now his family was middle class very
Catholic like his dad was a school
master
and uh
apparently his dad was not real down
with his whole like his son's artistic
temperament I guess because Han liked to
his name's uh henrikus actually but Han
was like a nickname
he was more into like painting and
drawing and [ __ ] like that uh and of
course his dad thought that was useless
so his dad was kind of always [ __ ]
on him all the time one of the stories
they tell about him as a kid was that
his dad would always kind of like make
him write 100 like like in school you
know how they make you write like 100
times on a piece of paper or some [ __ ]
that made him right
um I know nothing I am nothing I am
capable of nothing that's nice like that
your dad does that to you I'm sure that
doesn't have an effect on your life at
all but yeah so his dad really sounds
like a douche so anyway
uh so yeah so his dad thought like you
know art
painting drawing stuff like that was a
useless profession little did he know so
he's like well you can study
architecture that's at least something
useful
so he sent him to delft now delft was
the town uh that Jan Vermeer was from
which you know will that that'll be
significant later on so he sent him
there to study architecture
now
um pretty much like Han was just kind of
like he was really good at the whole
architecture thing like he passed all
the tests and everything but he just
never took the finals he was like look I
don't really give a [ __ ] about
architecture I don't want to be an
architect I want to be a painter
um but he it wasn't because he was like
bad at it he was like actually really
good at it and like won some awards and
[ __ ] and he actually did
um he designed the clubhouse for his
Rowing Club like in delft and it's still
there like to this day so there's that
now while he was at school
he actually met this one of his teachers
who was a painter and that this guy's
name was bartis cortelling
now he kind of like took Han under his
wing
now cortelling was a big fan of Jan
Vermeer Johannes Vermeer and he
basically showed uh Han van meegren how
Vermeer had made his colors because like
I said back in the old days when Jan
Vermeer was painting uh you couldn't
just go to Michael's and buy oil paint
you had to grind your own pigments and
mix them with you know you mix them with
oil you mix them with whatever egg
whites oh well no that's temporary
that's mostly like yeah this would be
like oil paint
so but yeah you usually had to like
grind your own stuff so he actually
showed him how Vermeer had done it so
like I said this is kind of like pretty
early on in his career
now the thing about it too is that
um bartis cortelling and as well as uh
Han van meegren they were really not
about this because you have to think
this is late 19th century early 20th
century All the Rage Modern Art
impressionism surrealism all that kind
of stuff
um and cortelling and Van meegerand were
not having it they just wanted to go
back to the classics the Old Masters
they thought all of this new [ __ ] like
impressionism and surrealism and cubism
and all that kind of stuff was
degenerate it was that kind of stuff so
you know
um and that I kind of feel like
cortelling's uh feelings in that regard
that he just thought all of the modern
art was just like [ __ ] and was like it
signaled like the end of civilization or
whatever I've seen the defense of what
they're talking about there's something
to be said from from what they're saying
but they're they're they're they're
they're they're they're overreacting to
it
they're too art Centric it doesn't
matter what some dude paints
they were just saying man you're not
supposed to do that to the human form it
[ __ ] up the mind when you look at stuff
like that and the humans don't look that
way that's a distortion of humans you're
doing psychological damage to people
when you [ __ ] [ __ ] up their
appreciation for beauty and stop warping
people's idea of what beauty is
so I can't understand what they're
talking about from a film though from a
philosophical standpoint I understand
what they're talking about is just that
it doesn't matter it sounds the art
world doesn't matter everything like
that sounds like old man yelling at
Cloud pretty much
every every time somebody says something
you say what you want and they say what
they want I'm just saying that's what it
sounds like every time I hear that I'm
like all right grandpa yeah yeah I don't
think they were old though no but I'm
just when I say grandpa that I don't
necessarily mean you're old in age I
mean that you're old in Attitude they
were just saying it was disrespectful
when I call you Grandpa and you
shouldn't be messing with people well
there are some there is some [ __ ] I
agree with them along that point like
I've seen them build buildings that are
just [ __ ] atrocious they're like you
got to be a [ __ ] [ __ ] to make a
building look like that and that
motherfucker's ugly you know looks like
a damn prison block you know what I mean
and then and then later on you find out
that yeah there was kind of a damn
psychological motive behind doing that
and uh like one of the things that I was
thinking about is like some of the
Soviet some of the Soviet
buildings that they built were designed
to uh
to intimidate people with like bleakness
and uh uh you know what I mean like the
secret police building would just look
like as Bleak as [ __ ] so there the
people the people that make that [ __ ]
sometimes do have a psychological motive
behind it oh yeah I'm not saying that
and I'm not saying that there's not some
art and some architecture that I
personally think is ugly yeah
um a lot of stuff that I think is ugly I
usually find it ugly if it's just like
functional
I mean I kind of like buildings that
they kind of like pimped out some like
make it look cool like make it look
beautiful like it doesn't matter if
there's a bunch of stuff on there that's
not functional you know but I think that
there's a lot to be said for like you
know making things look beautiful just
for the sake of them being yeah but
that's not the Soviet building I was
talking about the one that one that they
actually pointed out was totally
functional but it was it was designed to
be Bleak and hopeless looking so when
you saw it was like an immovable object
that dominated you and if you went in
there you'd never come out that would
and that was literally what it was they
were trying to make you feel when you
saw it there's some kind of KGB building
that they built it was something you
were supposed to see it and have dread
for it and you know and evidently it
achieved its purpose yeah well like I
said anything that looks like that I
just think is ugly it doesn't like
intimidate me or anything it was like
that I'm just like wow it's just ugly he
was real ugly
because it doesn't you know like I said
it doesn't have any it doesn't look like
it has any beauty to it or anything I
remember correctly you know I haven't
seen in a long time it was just square
and squat had pipes on the outside of it
yeah machine and you were supposed to
see that thing and go I don't want to go
in there but they would make you go in
there it was where they were gonna this
is where they were gonna [ __ ] torture
you basically
wasn't that isn't there like an art
I can't remember it's been a long time
since I took art appreciation it was
probably been like 20 years but they're
like what is brutalist architecture is
usually just like functional square
right without any kind of like I think
that's what they call it yeah well
that's how they had that thing hooked up
it was some kind of secret police
station
Mr 88 said I find Victorian era interior
design atrocious it makes one's eye
twitch I love minimalism others feel the
exact opposite honestly
um I like both things depending on how
they're done
um minimalism I think looks really good
in certain applications like if
something's just like really you know
like lots of open space and stuff like
it I don't know it depends on the space
it depends on like how it's utilized
like sometimes I really like that too
um but I'm usually more a fan of kind of
like more Victorian or Baroque or things
like that no leave it leave it I'm just
gonna put it in the other room leave it
it's fine it's driving me crazy
um but you know I tend to like uh Zach
said I'm still obsessed with 1920s or
lately yeah it's like mine too like I
really like art deco Art Nouveau I like
stuff like that which some people think
might be too much which like I said
that's fine I like minimalism in some
applications too like I said like some
Victorian stuff I've seen yeah it's like
there's too much crap it's too crowded
and stuff like that I get it but it
depends how it looks though a lot of the
modern interpretation of Victorian stuff
looks a lot better than the way it
really did if you look at some of the
some of the early crime scene
photography and [ __ ] that was around
during the Victorian early photography
where they were taking pictures of stuff
you see the Interiors the way they
really looked back in those days it
looked like a damn funeral home
you know and it was kind of dark in
there and they had weird [ __ ] up around
the corners and stuff and weird cabinets
and it just
some of that Victorian stuff that the
average person lived in not rich people
but what average people lived in was
[ __ ] spooky looking man
if you want to know like what I would
actually like if I had money and could
like design a house the way I wanted
um it would either look like that [ __ ]
from Suspiria like the original Suspiria
not the Remake
um or the like the really really like
Art Nouveau looking building in um that
GLA movie that I just talked about the
other day that I can't remember but yeah
that one
um although that was kind of like a ruin
but
you know I mean if it was like nice like
those windows and stuff I just like
really wanted those but you know what I
mean it's just but I like minimalism too
in certain applications so
I don't know I I have styles that I like
but I'm always open to new things you
know what I mean like I'm usually more
into like as far as art is concerned I'm
usually more into kind of more classical
kind of stuff or like you know kind of
more Old Masters type stuff but when I
went to when I go to Modern Art Museums
like when I went to MoMA and New York
and stuff like that like I saw some [ __ ]
in there that I thought was like pretty
awesome like for example I had seen
pictures of like for like Jackson
Pollock in books and things like that
because like I said I took lots of art
appreciation like in college and stuff
like that and I was always just kind of
like yeah I could see why people would
like that but I'm not really into it but
when I saw
a Jackson Pollock in person
um I was like oh like I get it now you
know what I mean it's a lot different
seeing one in person than seeing a
picture of one you know what I mean so
there's that too
but generally I tend to kind of prefer
but I do like a lot like I know there
was like a few years ago that was kind
of like a big surge in kind of low Brow
Art I guess is what they called it where
it was kind of people that were into
like old comic books and all that kind
of stuff that were coming up with all
this kind of [ __ ] and you know they're
artists like Travis Louis who actually
met in New York where he would do like
these really weird portraits that were
kind of like old Victorian portraits but
they were like animal heads or like
people that had like weird deformities
or were like Monsters and stuff and they
were [ __ ] super cool so I really
liked that kind of oh and that guy who's
that guy God damn it I can't remember
his name but he did these sculptures
that were like that would come out from
the wall and they were like like kind of
monster heads like werewolves and stuff
but they looked like they were made of
like cake frosting
and they were like really really cool I
was like super into those they were
really really cool looking so I like uh
kind of that kind of stuff but you never
I don't know you never know what I'm
gonna like until I look at it because
I've got I have like a very broad uh
thing I have things that I like but you
never know you never know
so uh so yeah so basically so these two
uh crotchety gold bars these these
crotchety young Parts
um we're just like oh this new art today
it is these kids today with their van
goghs and their this and they're that it
was that kind of thing that's what I'm
imagining but they didn't they didn't
like it they said it was degenerate I'm
gonna [ __ ] I'm gonna still defend
some of what some of the [ __ ] that they
said
I actually saw
posters okay of the [ __ ] prop the the
the Nazi propaganda posters against the
degenerate Arts you can find them on
YouTube
what they're showing is degenerate art
does suck all right it's just shitty
drawings
but what's funny is the reaction to it
they're overreacting to it yes it's as
if art is important I never really
thought art was that important but
basically all they're saying is these
are memes it's it's from another era
they didn't have internet back then but
it was the equivalent of [ __ ]
somebody just posting this sucks they
had to get outraged about something well
there was a bunch of stuff it was
cultural it was a cultural revolution
and some people aren't happy they're
getting outraged it's about something
that doesn't mean anything it's the same
it's the same thing that happens online
it was the equivalent that's what I'm
saying it's the equivalent of making
something saying in the comment section
this sucks
people
crying nowadays oh my God this this
movie like raped my childhood it's like
that I'm just like shut up like but I
think everybody got that I think
everybody kind of makes
makes a big deal out of it not only were
the was mustache man and his prop and
his party making a big deal over shitty
Arc
people come in and make a big deal over
them saying that the art was shitty too
you know what I mean when really saying
that the art was shitty wasn't important
to begin with because the art wasn't
important it was equivalent to somebody
saying something on a damn YouTube
channel on a YouTube video it's really
back in those days there was no medium
other than print so if you print
something or make a poster
[ __ ] it for some reason in the human
mind it becomes more important whoa they
printed that wow look at that picture oh
they said that in print
whoa it's on the news it's all equal
it's all [ __ ]
it just happened to be part of the
conversation at the time and it got
frozen in history as well they didn't
like the bad art or they didn't like or
they liked the good art or wow but
that's just part of the nature of the
show I guess that's nature of human
beings you know what I mean they make
comments
uh yeah the art sucked I saw I saw what
they were talking about but Van Gogh and
the other ones
they didn't make any comments about that
they probably would have been forced to
say it sucked under [ __ ] social
pressure but it's obvious that viago
doesn't suck that's pretty good Hein van
meeger and hated Van Gogh yeah but it's
obvious that goes pretty good
venko is a genius yeah yeah I'm not a
huge fan of impressionism but I really
do like Vancouver and stuff and I and I
concede that that's just a personal
taste thing I know a lot of people
really like impressionism it's not my
thing but I honor on the other hand I
have seen some impressionist paintings
that I actually really really liked that
I would hang on my walls yeah there's
that too the Nazis probably would have
burned Van Gogh
but they probably would have burned
burned Van Gogh thinking that's pretty
good but we got to burn it we got to
burn it because that's we have to stay
on first we gotta stay on brand right
that's exactly what they would have done
yeah that's how mustache man and those
guys were it was all about principle and
the narrative they had to stay inside
their narrative
there to go [ __ ] yeah we gotta burn it
okay
uh Mr 88 said Nazis hated art because
they couldn't understand it yeah
probably to a degree uh creativity
breeds critical thinking and they could
not have that yeah that was probably
something to do with the two yeah yeah
probably I say no it probably was they
understood our they wanted to control it
that's that's what they wanted they saw
artist propaganda but it wasn't just
them the Soviets were the same way the
only art that existed in Soviet Russia
was propaganda art that's what it was
they knew when they knew quality when
they saw it it's just that they wouldn't
allow it
that's what it was they they did not
there was a medium that both of those
parties wanted to control
and if it didn't have if it wasn't
making a political statement that
supported their narrative they didn't
allow it that's what it was
mrady is talking about uh English
medieval art actually I really really
like a lot of medieval art I love
stained glass I love all of that uh kind
of old religious art like from The 14th
Century
um I've that's one of my actually
favorite uh sections of the met in New
York is all of the the big medieval
section with all the stained glass
windows and stuff it's cut it's
beautiful beautiful
but I'm just I'm kind of like man if
people want to make art make art I don't
care what it looks like like I said
you're trying to like you try to control
narratives like that yeah
um you're gonna have a bad time the
Russians were all about controlling the
political narrative and it all had to be
about Marxism socialism communism and
class struggle that was the narrative
with the Germans it was also that but it
had a racial element to it they didn't
want anybody outside the Germanic sphere
saying anything in art
so if it wasn't really a Germanic artist
it was going to either be destroyed or
be at the bottom because they wanted to
control narrative yeah that's what Mark
said
totalitarian yeah it wasn't from them it
had to be exactly it didn't have
anything to do with the quality of it it
had to do with who was saying it they
were just trying to ban people out of
the space it was like Banning somebody
off Twitter like that but just uh in
those days the medium was one of the
mediums was art art and print and you
know they're just trying to dominate
they're basically dominating their
version of the internet
so
okay so let's get back to this so yeah
so van meeger and uh him and his buddy
are like uh whining about degenerate art
as I imagine they would in 1911 uh he
knocked up his girlfriend
named Anna De root uh she was a
Protestant he was a Catholic apparently
that wasn't a thing so they got married
and had a couple kids now he started
working as an assistant drawing
instructor which I think was the only
like real job he ever had like he got
rich later on but yeah this was the only
real job he ever had
now 1917 he moved to the Hague
and there he started working as an
artist now the thing about
again I kind of feel like the popular
narrative about Han van meegerin is that
he wasn't successful as a real artist
like with his own stuff so he said [ __ ]
it I'm gonna start faking things and
show you [ __ ] that's not
exactly the case because he was actually
kind of successful with his own artwork
it's just that
um he wasn't really like all that
original
um he was mostly like kind of hearkening
back to Old Styles kind of copying old
Styles and some critics like called him
out for that
and he got his feelings hurt over it and
maybe that was kind of like what
inspired him to but honestly I kind of
feel like he started with the forgery
thing
earlier than that just like to make more
money because he did make some money
with his um matter of fact his most
famous work of art which was kind of
like this little
painting uh drawing kind of thing of
like a little like a deer like a doe or
whatever
um it actually got quite famous and like
they sold prints of it like all over the
Netherlands and stuff like that so he
wasn't
it wasn't like he was a starving artist
you know what I mean was like oh nobody
understands me or nobody's like he was
like a fairly successful
commercial artist I guess like you know
he had some paintings that you know were
kind of popular and like sold prints and
things like that and he was making a
living at it like he was making a living
teaching and stuff like that but like I
said some of the critics didn't like his
[ __ ] because they were all into modern
art and he was doing like some old [ __ ]
and he wasn't really that original and
so they kind of like picked on him about
it and he didn't like it so you know
there was that whole thing
um so so that's the thing now his first
he usually had an art show like in The
Hague in 1917 and he had like a whole
bunch of different that was another
thing too is that as an artist he didn't
seem to have much uh Focus I kind of
feel like his portraits were his best
work but he did Landscapes he did like a
bunch of other [ __ ] too
um his first show that he had actually
got really positive reviews like nobody
should know about that
um but then he started going more into
like kind of Throwbacks type of stuff
like old like religious paintings like
Old Masters type of stuff and like I
said this is early 20th century you know
the trend was more toward Modern Art so
if you were gonna do something that was
just hearkening back to classicism or
stuff that had already been done then
yeah the critics were gonna be like yeah
well we've seen this done better you
know 400 years ago so like why aren't
you like bringing something new to the
table and it's they were just kind of
picking on him for not being creative
like pretty much so I think he kind of
got upset with that and I think they
thought that a lot of his religious
paintings that he did a little bit later
were a little bit
saccharin you know what I mean like
we're just a little bit too like I said
it was kind of like the pure flicks of
paintings like I kind of feel like it
was that kind of [ __ ] and that's what
they were negatively responding to maybe
I mean yeah so like his original Arts I
know that he's known nowadays mostly for
his forgeries but he did thousands and
thousands of his own original paintings
as well like and drawings
um he kind of did like he did a lot of
still lives he did a lot of but like I
said a lot of his stuff was kind of like
a throwback to 17th century that kind of
stuff
um he even did like some weird like
surrealistic kind of paintings would you
think that he wouldn't do because that
wasn't his thing but
yeah so he did a lot of his own work as
well
so basically as time went on even though
when he first came out like everybody
said it was very promising and stuff
like that but as time went on and it
seemed that he was like I said not
really focusing on a style but just kind
of going back and doing it seemed like
he wasn't copying other like artists
stuff but he was just kind of like not
coming up with anything different I
guess
so I kind of feel like the critics
started to maybe
maybe not turn against him but they were
just kind of like oh it's a shame he was
like started out with so much talent but
now he's just kind of like retreading
like the same ground I kind of feel like
they were talking about that kind of
stuff
see that's the thing and
he kind of spun the narrative later on
because like I said no we're still
talking about like 1917 but later on
like in the 1940s like after the trial
which you know like that's coming up
he basically said
um you know that he was he tried to make
himself like sound like a victim he was
like uh driven into a state of anxiety
and depression uh due to the all too
meager appreciation of my work like
nobody loves me so I was forced into
doing this I kind of feel like he was
like playing the victim card a little
bit
um he says this is what he said I
decided one fateful day to Revenge
myself on the art critics and experts by
doing something the likes of which the
world had never seen before so a little
bit self-aggrandizing a little bit a
historical because I kind of feel like
he was saying this at a time I feel like
I don't know I know the popular
narrative like I said is that he's like
oh God no one appreciates me so I'm just
gonna like I'm gonna [ __ ] all you guys
over by like painting a bunch of fakes
and making you fall for it
um I kind of feel like he was doing
fakes and copies and stuff like that
before all of this [ __ ] because you know
what I mean I kind of feel like he was
just kind of like oh maybe I can make
money doing that because he already knew
a lot of stuff about the Old Dutch
Masters and about like their techniques
and stuff so I kind of feel and he was
already painting copies which a lot of
painters do it's not somebody pointed
out in the comments it's like it's not
illegal to copy paintings it's like my
ex-husband was an oil painter and he
used to copy paintings all the time but
for practice like he didn't sell them
like and say hey it's a Rembrandt or
anything like that even though he
painted in that style like he painted
like things that looked like Rembrandt
or he copied like some Rembrandt
paintings but he was just like
practicing you know what I mean like he
didn't sell them or pretend that they
were actually Rembrandt so a lot of
artists do that but when you try to sell
it and pass it off with something yeah
then that's fraud
doing that kind of stuff like he was
copying a lot of Old Dutch Masters
so that's the thing it's uh I don't know
I just kind of feel like
this whole narrative that he was trying
to sell that oh nobody loved me and
nobody understood me so I felt the need
to [ __ ] everyone over and you guys
forced me into it I kind of feel like
that was a narrative that he was later
on trying to sell like when his ass was
on the line you know the genius of that
[ __ ] it's already it's already in the
jar so you don't even drink a moonshine
it's already just put the ice in the
[ __ ] is when it came it's already in
the jar
foreign
just put the I put put ice in the butter
pecan but that's it's a lot of calories
now well that's not I mean the butter
pecan thing is you really gotta like
that's like a dessert that's like
drinking melted ice cream it's delicious
but you gotta yeah it's not it's online
with [ __ ] like uh what do you call it
baby it's like Bailey cream it's like
Bailey's it tastes very much like
Bailey's except with a little bit it's a
little bit buttered pecan whatever
so yeah so the thing about it too is
that I kind of feel like as van meegerin
got more into painting copies and fakes
and things like that he made a lot more
money
but I wonder sometimes how much more
like if he had actually tried to develop
his own artistic style because he seemed
very talented uh I will say that a lot
of his fakes aren't that great but um
you know he seemed very talented
otherwise and it's like if he had maybe
applied himself to
developing his own style then maybe
he might have been successful that way
instead of being success more successful
as a forger I don't know the thing about
it is that he was so successful as a
forger I mean he was a millionaire many
times over so he didn't live very long
though I mean he died pretty young so
there was that it's just kind of like I
don't know how it would have worked out
so basically even though he kind of said
that oh it's you know after critics
started like [ __ ] on me then I
decided I was gonna like start forging
[ __ ] just like [ __ ] them over but
um a recent book about the case well
it's not that reason I think it came out
in 2008
um was like he's pretty sure that van
meeguran started [ __ ] around with uh
forgeries and art swindlers and stuff
like that in like 1920 and that's at the
very latest so
it's a lot earlier than most people like
posit that he first started [ __ ]
around with art forgery yeah 1920. I
like what Mark in the comment section
says he says in the end the commies and
the Nazis were all Hypocrites because
they stashed all the good art for
themselves absolutely true Ben and art
and burning art and [ __ ] that was just
to keep it out of the hands of the
plebes
all the good [ __ ] they kept and put that
[ __ ] in their homes exactly yeah
Daniel because you just because you tell
the plebes Something to Believe In
doesn't mean you believe in it it's just
a system you give to them that's a way
totalitarianism is always like that
Mr 88 said commercial artist so he casts
the mold for Thomas Kinkade in his ilk
bastard yeah
poor Thomas Kinkade we should do a show
about that guy yeah we did a show about
Bob Ross I don't know like uh Thomas
Kinkade
um
I don't really know much about Thomas
Kinkade as a person but I have seen like
uh his stores and malls where they sell
it's like they're and they're not
terrible it's just kind of like [ __ ]
that would hang in a hotel room or an
Airbnb or something you know what I mean
not offensive but nothing that you would
look twice at you know what I'm saying
which
you know
people like I guess people like that I
don't know
evidently enough people like it that he
has like stores and malls all over the
country so there's that and even some of
them light up I think like they have
little lights in them so I don't know uh
but yeah
so uh according to this other book that
was written about him they said that Han
van meeguren uh actually had another
Mentor who was a a painter and also like
an art dealer this guy named Theo van
wyngarten wind Garden
and he basically him and like this other
guy named Leo nardis they would they
would kind of like work together it's
like one of them would paint cut fakes
and then the other one would be like a
dealer and he would like approach a
bunch of American millionaires I'm
assuming like new money kind of people
and be like hey like we got this [ __ ]
whatever like they would show them like
this art
and uh you know and the dumb suckers
would buy it so they kind of had like a
whole thing going on and they think
maybe that van meegren was like up with
those people
um so yeah so basically
they sold a bunch of stuff to this guy
who was
um named Widener p p a b Weidner and he
was like a big streetcar magnate like
back in the day when streetcars were
like a thing and he had bought like a
[ __ ] ton of art from them and then but
like later on he found out that his
whole collection uh was worth like about
five percent of what he had originally
been charged for it because they were
pretty much all fakes so there was that
now one thing that uh this particular
guy Theo van wingarten did he came up
with a paint medium which like I said
that's something you mix with your paint
like when you're
painting on the canvas it was this kind
of like gelatin glue
and what this glue would do was
because when an oil painting is being uh
you know they're seeing if it's off when
it's being authenticated one of the
things they'll do is they'll rub the
painting with alcohol
because if the alcohol is or if the
paint isn't that old because oil paint
uh takes a really really long time to
dry
so if this oil paint is only like a few
years old uh then the alcohol will
dissolve it now if the painting is a few
hundred years old then the alcohol won't
dissolve it because it's had enough time
to fry yeah and Harden so apparently
this guy has developed this gelatin glue
that will kind of like circumvent the
alcohol test
um and he had made like a bunch of fakes
and sold them to this American
millionaire
um the problem was that even though this
gelatin glue uh worked on the alcohol
test if you got the painting wet uh it
would like soften and kind of like start
to fall off like just with water like if
you rubbed alcohol on it it was fine but
if you put water on it it would like
start so you know you can't win them all
I guess
um so yeah
uh so the whole thing about that so van
uh so this guy like van wingarten these
names are killing me these Dutch names
now he was a painter himself but he
didn't
he wasn't a good enough painter to like
pass off fakes of like you know really
good artists right so when he found van
meeguran who had studied like a lot of
the Old Dutch Masters and kind of like
knew a lot of their techniques and knew
a lot how of how they painted like uh
you know their the way that they painted
um he's just like yeah well we need to
like hook up and you need to paint some
paintings and I'll like help you pass
them off
so as I mentioned earlier
van meegrine was you know a pretty
popular painter in his own right like
before he even started forging stuff
um now he did paint some copies in 1923
he did
um a painting uh called the happy smoker
and he did one called The Laughing
Cavalier which were
um they weren't copies of actual
paintings but they were in the style of
France Halls
but he didn't like try to pass them off
as that so like I said that's something
that a lot of painters do
they'll copy paintings or do something
in the style of that like to see if they
can do it like for practice but he
wasn't at this point like trying to pass
them off as actually by that artist
now uh at this point too I kind of feel
like the critics were getting even more
mad because they're just kind of like
look you're just copying stuff by like
Old Dutch Masters like I said like Peter
de Hooch or uh you know or France halls
or whatever and it's just like why don't
you do your own [ __ ] uh and he wasn't
doing that
now at this point so he moves to the
Hague right and then he uh had kind of
like thrown over his first wife
and then he hooked up with this other
woman whose name was uh Johanna Deboer
and she was an actress so she was a
little bit more like libertine I guess
uh and he was kind of into that
and they were actually together for a
really long time we'll talk about that
later but um and I guess she kind of
like put up with it because I think he
kind of like uh was kind of a little bit
of man [ __ ] a little bit
um he's got to do you know and he was
kind of he was also an alcoholic yeah
well you know so there's a lot of time
on his hands so there was that and
apparently like she just put up with it
I guess
um Story Goes that uh that van meager
and like once he started like making
some money he had uh you know once he
started kind of like doing the forgery
thing yeah he actually had a separate
party house like he had his house and he
had the party house he'd bring the girls
and uh yeah and it's yeah they bring the
prostitutes in and he had like little
reportedly he had like little like uh
Treasure Chest like full of jewels and
it's like hey take what you want you
know what I mean it's all here yeah yeah
Mississippi has those they call them
[ __ ] hunting lodges and fishing
cabins that's where you take the
girlfriend
yeah that's kind of like what he yeah
what he had going on yeah that's kind of
what he had going on
uh but yeah so remember how I mentioned
earlier that he really hated Vincent van
Gogh this is um
so what I want to get to say is that
even though a lot of people still think
of Han van meegren as like you know
National Dutch national hero and stuff
like that but one thing that he did say
in regards to uh Modern Art and how much
he hated it
was that um he started publishing like
once the critics started like getting on
his ass about why you just like
reproducing like all this old [ __ ]
he had a little uh magazine that he put
out every month I don't know what the
circulation of it was but he started
like writing all these articles in it
and he basically called
[Music]
um
his uh modern painting the proponents of
modern painting are a slimy bunch of
Woman Haters and negro lovers that's
what he called them okay
um and basically he called the uh a
symbol of the international Art Market
was a Jew with a hand cart
so I was like okay so like I said what's
the hand cart mean I have no idea going
around trying to make money I guess okay
like hey put all the money in here you
put the money in here so like I said
he's cheap ASR yeah yeah
so um so yeah so the narrative goes that
he's like oh I'm this big genius and
nobody loves me and nobody recognizes it
so I'm going to prove to the art critics
that I can do more than copy you know
these old classical artists I'm gonna
produce something that's like so awesome
that you guys are just it's gonna be as
good as theirs and I'll be able to fool
everybody
so at this point he takes his girlfriend
slash wife the actress they go off to
the south of France and he is like I'm
gonna produce like the ultimate forgery
but like I said you have to admire his
hutzpah because he spent a long time
doing this okay and I'm not gonna say
like he didn't half-ass it she said I
did Jenny became Yiddish all of a sudden
what it's a word I know
I can use that word if I wanted
so yeah so they so they go there and he
spends like six years
um developing his techniques now there's
kind of a lot of debate over how much
that's very distracting you know I'm
sorry
she's throwing stuff okay yeah he's like
back there like moving around and I'm
just kind of like yeah my shit's going
back [ __ ] throwing [ __ ] at me and I'm
throwing it back it's so funny she's got
the little [ __ ] the little black
mouse and she's biting it and she threw
it at me through the back funny yeah
I've never seen her throw anything at me
yeah she's eating it yeah she threw
something at me that was the first time
I was like wow oh yeah Danny Rowling
said this guy looks like he was one of
the crew members on the Death Star in
Star Wars he does a little bit like in
the picture
I didn't see a lot of pictures of him as
a as a young person I kind of feel like
most of the pictures you see of him
online are like when he was old because
that's like after he got arrested but
yeah
uh so yeah
um a lot of people don't know how much
his wife uh Johanna knew about what he
was doing I kind of suspect she probably
knew but she probably didn't give a [ __ ]
because he eventually started making
like millions and millions of dollars
off of it and she's just kind of like
whatever as long as we're like have a
good lifestyle I want to give crap so
yeah so they moved to the French Riviera
um because I kind of feel like the more
like when he started selling the
forgeries and they started making all
this money like you know people wouldn't
like ask him about it because he wasn't
you know in his home country anymore so
he's kicking ass Jenny yeah I'll never
slow down on that moonshot well yeah
you're just you're already kind of like
yeah yeah man moving around yeah
[ __ ] let it wear off yeah
I mean this isn't like a hugely
complicated show but it's just like I
don't want it to be like all okay I
don't want it to like yeah we got a
storm coming and I got pizza getting
ready to go down oh okay I didn't know
that oh yeah that sounds good oh yeah
and that's that heavy bread crust dough
oh okay so it's gonna be good okay all
right
so like I said as practice like he
starts doing uh Gerardo board she starts
doing France Halls he starts doing like
all these kind of like famous uh Dutch
Masters and he did some by Johannes
Vermeer now he finally says okay what am
I gonna do for my ultimate forgery that
I'm gonna fool everybody with he chose a
painting by Vermeer uh and it was
probably probably the best thing for him
to do because Vermeer
um was a well-known painter in his time
but then he'd kind of been a little bit
forgotten about
um but then he kind of had a Resurgence
like right around 1850 1860.
um and so his work started to get like
really really valuable and they were
also really scarce because Vermeer that
they know of only produced about 35
paintings that you know that are
definitely attributed to him during his
lifetime so uh so van megren figures
Well everybody's super into Vermeer now
um it's right in my wheelhouse like
that's exactly what I can paint I know
how he you know ground his paints I know
how he worked and people are collectors
are really really looking for more I
mean 35 paintings that's it by this guy
so it's like he had to have painted more
than that like during his life so he's
like so collectors are going to be like
really if you kind of come up with a
loss Vermeer that's going to be like a
big deal and I can get a lot of money so
it was probably like the best artist
that he could have particularly picked
because like I said there weren't really
a lot of authenticated vermeers floating
around back that still aren't actually
um so he went all in he goes all into
like uh read all their biographies uh
you know their lives their whole uh the
way that they uh you know all of their
paintings like how they painted the
techniques the way they mix their paints
everything
um interestingly and this was kind of
like uh kind of an interesting I don't
know if it was a coincidence but there's
a guy named Dr Abraham bredius and he
was like a um Rembrandt expert and he
published an article in late 1932 and he
um was talking about two recently
discovered verb well they were
supposedly Vermeer paintings that had
just been you know discovered and one of
them was a landscape
um which Vermeer didn't do a lot of
Landscapes not that I remember
and uh there was another one with like a
man and woman like a spin it or Like a
Piano Thing
um now he thought that the landscape one
was fake but that the other one was
probably like authentic
so that kind of I think that made van
Meeker and be like oh now I'm no I'm
really on the right track because
everybody's like talking about here's
this guy that's like a rambrain expert
he's just like talking about these new
vermeers that they found and he's like
I'm gonna find some vermeers too you
know what I mean
so at this point him and his wife
they moved to this Village and Brent
this big ass Mansion which is called
Primavera and he starts like working on
all of the chemical and like technical
procedures that is gonna because like I
said it's not just painting the [ __ ]
that looks like the classic thing but
you have to make it look like it's from
that year which is not as easy as it
sounds
so what he would do was he would go and
buy like kind of shittier like mediocre
paintings from that time period
um you know the same time period where
the painting that he wanted to forge was
from like 17th century in this case
and then he would start mixing his own
paints from raw materials like I said
you know so you'd have like white lead
you had an indigo Cinnabar all that kind
of stuff and then he would use the old
formulas as much as was possible
so that if anybody went in there with
like chemical analysis that would look
like paint from that time period he also
went as far as creating his own Badger
hair paint brushes uh because that's
what Vermeer used so he wanted it
exactly the same
um one of the genius things that he did
and this is one of the things that I
remember the most I don't know why like
from the book that I read about him he
came up with this uh plan where he would
use essentially Bakelite uh and he'd mix
it in with the paint Bakery yeah and it
would um you know phenol formaldehyde is
what that is and he would mix it into
the paints and then when the paints so
the paints would Harden like really
really quickly so chemically it would
seem like it had it was like 300 years
old because like this again
um this was 1930s okay early 1930s
Bakelite is the prototype for plastic
yep yep Sophia started using it
in the 40s
for machine gun furniture and stuff
where it ended up on the AK-47 Bakelite
yeah you only found that [ __ ] really in
the time she's talking about you only
found Bakelite and things like pot
handles
for [ __ ] cooking pots because it
would isolate heat pretty well
weird material we're long gone long gone
you never see Bakelite anymore
it's very collectible now yes actually
it's kind of it was kind of a hard
glossy
resiny feeling plastic
but it wasn't really plastic I don't
think it came from petroleum products
like plastic
does it comes from other stuff but yeah
that's what he used like to make the
paint Harden really quick because
remember how I said earlier like a lot
of times if they thought something was
fake they put alcohol on it because if
the paint hadn't dried for decades or
centuries then the [ __ ] would rub right
off it's weird but Bakelite if you mixed
it in with it hard enough it would
harden up and it wouldn't rub off good
thing so yeah like I said so you do have
to get you know you did have to give
them credit for that for figuring
uh he would also mix his paints with
lilac oil uh which would kind of like
stop the paints from fading or yellowing
like when he applied heat to them which
is which is coming up
um and one thing he would do because he
didn't want anybody to catch him doing
that he always kept like um bouquets of
lilacs like in his studio so everybody
be like oh it smells like lilac in here
and it's like oh it's just those so you
know what I mean he didn't want anybody
to think that he was bored and [ __ ]
um so after he did all that uh you know
he'd put the bake light in the paint he
would paint the painting and then he
would bake it he'd pick bake the
painting about 100 degrees Centigrade
which is uh you know 212 Fahrenheit uh
to harden the paint and then he would
take the painting and roll it over a
cylinder like to get the the cracks you
know what I mean because you know
paintings that are 300 years old have a
bunch of cracks in them and then he
would take black India ink and he'd like
kind of like wash it over the whole
thing so that like dirt like black would
go down into the crack so it would look
old
so that's what he did
um like I said it took about six years
and if you want to know more about it
it's actually like fascinating I got
like really into science behind it
um there's a couple of really good books
about them I think they both came out in
2008 um you can find just Han van meeger
in 2008 whatever and um one of the books
that I read like went really into his
methods and it was like really
interesting Glenn's asking when they
stopped making bake like last time I saw
a bake light it was in the mid 90s
I bought a rat milk cool gear AK-74
rifle from Romania and it had Bakelite
pistol grip on it just a pistol grip not
the butt stock or the the forearms and
they have the Orange Bake Light
that's the last time I've seen it it was
in the 90s and that was Romania
but it seemed to be fake light
so
yeah I'd have to look that up because I
just remember seeing like years ago that
I don't know about now but I remember
years ago like seeing some Antiques
Roadshow or something like that and they
were talking about like how
um there was like a kind of a Resurgence
and people that collected stuff that was
made of Big Lake like from back in the
day but
I don't know if that's still like
ongoing because they made all kind of
stuff about
out of that back then
so so yeah so like I said it took him
about six years and he painted a bunch
of
um paintings like practice ones that he
didn't sell like he did
um they weren't exactly copies of
Vermeer paintings but they were like in
the style of Vermeer he did one called
like lady reading music
um which was kind of similar to an
actual Vermeer painting and um that's
actually still on display it's in the
Rights Museum in Amsterdam and he did
another one uh that was based off of
vermeer's woman with a loot narrow
window uh which is in the Met
um so I've actually been to the met so
I've seen like some of vermeer's
paintings in real life uh I don't know
if I I don't remember if I saw any green
ones I kind of feel like I did but I
can't remember it was a long time ago so
like I said these two he didn't sell he
was that he just did them for practice
see if he could pull it off
so 1936 van meeguran uh paints he his uh
kind of like first big Vermeer forgery
and this was uh the supper at Emmaus
now he used like the same kind of like
blues and yellows that they would have
used back then that Vermeer would have
used
now what he had done like I said he
would usually buy like shitty old
paintings or not shitty but like just
ones that weren't you know worth
anything like from the era so he could
have the canvas and kind of use it as a
you know as a base or whatever
so he bought this painting from the 17th
century like a Dutch painting that was
called The Awakening of Lazarus and then
he used that as like the basic canvas
so basically what he decided to do was
that because a lot of uh Vermeer experts
thought that Vermeer had studied in
Italy and I'm not sure if that's the
case but everybody thought that it was
so van meeguran probably very
intelligently decided you know what I'm
gonna do I'm going to if I'm going to
paint uh separate Emmaus which is like a
big uh you know uh
topic that a lot of painters are back
then painted
um you know Bible kind of thing
so he's like I'm gonna go and I'm gonna
use the Caravaggio supper at Emmaus and
I'm going to base it off of that like
the composition because it's like then
that makes it look like Vermeer painted
it but he had been studying in Italy and
was looking at caravaggio's work and
he's like so like I said he wasn't dumb
he like knew what he was and he kind of
knew his Market too you know what I mean
so he's like that's what I'm gonna do so
he painted it like that
now the thing about it
here's one thing and I kind of want to
get into this a little bit later too
because I've seen actual vermeers
and the painting even and the separate
Emmaus is probably van meegeren's best
forgery
and it's not very good
even me a Layman who has just seen a few
vermeers in real life and has seen a
bunch of them in books
knows that that's not a Vermeer it just
doesn't look like it's similar but it
doesn't look like an actual Vermeer so
people just want to believe well I think
that was a big deal because like I said
Vermeer had just kind of come back into
Vogue and he didn't paint that many
paintings in his life at least that
people know of so collectors were like
really really it was kind of like a hot
commodity so if somebody comes out and
it kind of looks like a Vermeer but he's
like yeah sure it's a Vermeer you know
and they'll buy it because they want
they want it to be they want it to be a
Vermeer but like because that was the
best one and they didn't get any better
like they just kind of got the quality
of them got worse and worse like as time
went on
um I'm not saying that van meegram is a
bad painter it's just that his vermeers
don't look like vermeers to me like even
just from my unpractice eye they really
don't want that they're not terrible but
you can tell that's not a Premiere it's
not the same
but uh so yeah what he did with this one
so he could paint the [ __ ] right he had
all the techniques right it looked like
an old painting it was on an old canvas
all that kind of stuff
but the problem with it it's not so much
painting it and Faking It Is that how do
you get this out into the market without
anybody being suspicious
so what he would do
he kind of had some connections early on
but I guess like as time went on he kind
of like lost touch with them
so he started like developing his own
con
so he would basically try to trick
innocent people like friends of his into
like bringing the [ __ ] into the market
on his behalf
so on this particular painting
um he knew this guy named Gerard Boone
who uh interestingly he was kind of like
a parliamentarian like from the liberal
State party in uh in the Netherlands and
was a big advocate of like the right of
women to vote and stuff like that
now uh so van meegrin I guess kind of
knew this guy and see he convinced him
that it's like oh this painting uh
originally but it's a Vermeer and it
belonged to this Dutch family who were
in Italy and they got persecuted by the
fascists and they need some money to get
out of the country and go to the United
States so can you find a buyer for me uh
you know and this was [ __ ] now
interestingly it's kind of interesting
because Boone was actually kind of more
like a liberal and uh van meageren by
all accounts was more like an ultra
right kind of person which like I said
is really funny that he's gone down in
history as being like oh he [ __ ] over
the Nazis he was kind of a Nazi
sympathizer
um like I said the fact that he fooled
the Nazis that was just kind of
incidental he didn't really mean he's
just a dude who can move in those
circles and you've got to be like those
guys you just it just you know it's how
a con man works but yeah he passed this
painting off yeah as like he knew how to
appeal to this guys he's like oh this
family and it's like they got [ __ ]
over by the fascists in Italy and it's
like they need some money it's a Vermeer
they really need to sell it
so uh so Boone was like okay that's
that's fine so he shows the painting to
the guy I mentioned earlier the
Rembrandt uh expert whose name was uh
Abraham bredius who was an artist Oran
and so bernius looks at this forgery in
1937 and he accepted it as a genuine
Vermeer and thought it was a masterpiece
like I said it's not a terrible painting
but
I don't know it's maybe knowing what I
know I'm just looking at it going it
doesn't look exactly like a Vermeer to
me but I don't know now
um all of the tests they did do
scientific tests on it and [ __ ] like
that like they did all kind of like the
white lead analysis the x-rays all that
kind of stuff and the painting like
passed all the tests because he knew
like I said vanbi girl wasn't a dummy he
knew what he was doing so he did try to
like make everything as
you know he tried to lock everything
down like as much as possible and it did
work for like a very long time
now the painting was actually purchased
by the Rembrandt Society for uh at that
time 520 000 florins which is about
which is
4.6 million euros today
um and then it was donated to a museum
in Rotterdam and they also had like this
big in 1938 that this big special
exhibition like oh look at this Vermeer
we just found blah blah blah with like a
bunch of other like old uh like
legitimate assumed uh you know Dutch
Masters
so at this point like
you know uh van meegren is like
cha-ching he's like cashed in 1938 he
moves to nice in France and uh buys a 12
bedroom estate
so he made like a [ __ ] Donald yeah this
dude made a lot of money a lot
um so while he was at this mansion
he actually painted a couple more
forgeries uh he did one called interior
with card players and interior with
drinkers which were both they weren't
vermeers they were actually uh Peter de
Hooch uh who was another very famous
Dutch painter and uh he also painted a
Last Supper in the style of Vermeer now
he went back to the Netherlands in
September of 1939 uh as the second world
war was kind of looming now throughout
1941
he actually kind of put out a book of um
this big huge like really fancy uh book
of all his drawings and uh so he did
that and he did a bunch of forgeries
around this time too like uh you know
just a whole bunch of uh Vermeer copies
like he did a [ __ ] ton of them it wasn't
just Vermeer but I think that's the ones
that he was the most famous for and
that's kind of the ones that he did
during this time period now
interestingly like I said he wasn't a
dummy there's a lot of things you could
say about van Binger but he wasn't
stupid
December 1943
he actually divorced his wife
but he didn't really divorce he only
legally divorced her like they kept
living together he was starting to make
so much money that he put a bunch of
money in her name and he's like hey if I
ever get busted or caught or anything
like that and they make me like they
take all my money or my estate or
whatever he wanted a place to like put
it so he put up the [ __ ] all in her name
and then he divorced her so they
wouldn't have any like legal thing but
they still kept living together and it
did actually kind of like work out
so yeah they uh they didn't know what
was gonna happen because the war was
coming so he put all the money in her
name
in 1943 late 1943 they moved to
Amsterdam and then they uh they got this
like super super fancy house now like I
said his forgeries at this point had
earned him
um about by today's money about 30
million dollars damn 30 million Rich
[ __ ] yeah that's what I'm saying
uh he bought a wrong business right [ __ ]
all this YouTube
[ __ ] don't think I ever thought about it
yeah well like I said well companies the
thing about it is like
you kind of it's harder to afford
obviously it's harder to forge stuff
from centuries ago yeah because there's
a lot of like and and they know all the
tricks they now they have everything
like they can tell and he got busted
later on
microscope that's what I mean then
they'll be like well it's fake yeah and
it's very very easy
um you know and actually he like I said
he got busted back then too but nowadays
it'd be super easy so I kind of feel
like if you're gonna Forge some art like
Forge something more recent it'd be
easier like if you try to like Forge
stuff from like the [ __ ] 17th century
unless you really want to like go all in
on that [ __ ] because that's going to
cost you a lot of money to like [ __ ]
probably better Forge some Roman coins
and [ __ ] like that probably a lot easier
but they may not be the buyers who knows
you got to know exactly what you're
doing that's what I'm saying and that's
why in some ways
I'm not as mad at like art Forge because
look at all of the [ __ ] knowledge
that you have to have to even want to
get into this stuff yeah you're gonna I
mean if unless you know what you're
doing you're gonna get caught like
immediately
so you got to know the scene that's what
I mean these are from the scene yeah you
have to you don't have to you have to
know what people want what will people
buy and then you have to know well how
can I fake that so it's a like a lot of
work it's a lot of I mean if you're
gonna do that much work you might as
well just get a real job you know what
I'm saying in order to sell it you had
to be known right the only way to get
known is you got to sell real [ __ ] first
right so you got to build up the con
that's what I'm saying so it's unless
you're an art Thief you can just steal
the [ __ ] and then hold it for ransom and
that happens too yeah
yeah but you got to have a foolproof and
you better be ready to go to jail
because that's part of the bargaining
process yeah and if you let me out of
jail I'll give you the [ __ ] painting
but you got to pay us man that one guy
does that like right like every [ __ ]
couple of years or so he's willing to be
in jail three four five years he's just
like ah whatevs yeah he didn't give a
[ __ ] he goes no I get the painting for
you
but you gotta let me out you got to pay
a certain amount of money and I I think
I know who has it yeah you know that's
that's the game that's what he's decided
he wants to which right yeah hey if
that's the way you want to make money
then that's up to you you're sitting
there doing [ __ ] Shaolin [ __ ]
Buddhist monk stuff while [ __ ] Tai
Chi while he's locked up
[ __ ] saying I'm willing to wait
and he really was doing [ __ ] yeah
like if I'm willing to wait you know
they want that painting back they're
gonna [ __ ] yield you know I don't
have it
but I think I can get it I think I know
who has it it's going to take a certain
amount of money they're going to want a
certain amount of money so it's like
he's essentially holding them for Brands
yeah it's like his whole business yeah
yeah and then once I get this for you
you got to get me out of here you know
so but they know he [ __ ] stole that
[ __ ] he means but he and his boys stole
it well yes but no we get approving it
or two different prove it though and
that's what he's relying yeah he's like
well yeah you can know it all you want
but if you can't prove it then right
then you gotta let me out right which
like I said if that's the way you went
want to make money fine I'm just saying
that it's like
even though Han van meegren kind of
sounded like I don't know in some ways
he kind of sounded like a douche but you
do have to kind of respect that he went
all in with this forgery thing like he
may yeah he made a shitload of money out
of it but that's a lot of work though
like I said I think that's probably more
work than I would be willing to put in
and even and I like this kind of [ __ ]
but I'm like if I'm gonna put that much
work in I'd rather just like paint my
own original [ __ ] and like hope somebody
likes it enough to give me a million
dollars for it you know what I'm saying
instead of just like [ __ ] yeah I
gotta bake the [ __ ] and like mix it with
all this and do all this chemistry and
stuff like that [ __ ] that so yeah so he
had earned about 30 million dollars in
today's money
uh from his all of his forgeries that
he'd done mostly vermeers but not all
and he bought a [ __ ] ton of real estate
he bought a [ __ ] out of like expensive
jewelry of other people's art he bought
that too
um and was like you know living the High
Life man and he actually claimed in 1946
that he had
52 houses I don't know if that's true if
he was just bragging and 15 country
houses and some of those houses were
kind of like those Mansions like right
along the canals like in Amsterdam and
stuff I don't know if he really had that
much property if he was just like you
know dick swinging or whatever but he
did actually like say that he had I'm
like what are you gonna do with 52
houses actually more than 52 houses 52
000 and 15 country houses you can't live
in all those houses at once why are you
wasting your money like that so um so
this is how the [ __ ] got caught
and it's almost kind of like I don't
know if it's irony or it's something but
it's something like that
so in 1942 like when uh the Germans were
occupying the Netherlands
what ended up happening was that
somebody not not Han van meeger and like
directly but one of his agents that he
had out there like selling his forgeries
to people because you can't just like be
the artist you know you have to have
like middlemen like doing that [ __ ] so
he had like agents like selling the [ __ ]
to people
so one of his agents sold one of his
Vermeer forgeries
um which is uh Christ with the
adulteress I've seen it called or Christ
with the woman taking an adultery I've
seen it called that as well
so somebody had one of his agents sold
that
to the Nazi banker and art dealer uh
Alois middle whatever
um my German's not good either was Maidu
yeah yeah so
um so he sells it to that guy now as I
said this forgery really the separate uh
at Emmaus was really his best forgery
like all the other ones he didn't as
time went on he got richer and richer he
also got drunker and drunker
um and he also chain smoked and was also
a morphine addict so his uh forgeries
got a little bit less awesome as time
went on some of the later ones I've seen
pictures of I mean they
it wasn't exactly like kindergarten kind
of [ __ ] but I was just kind of like
really that fooled somebody all right do
anyone heard that yeah well yeah all
right
might as well uh but yeah so it wasn't
great is what I'm saying like the
quality of it but regardless uh this
person bought it like the Nazi Banker
bought it
um and the thing about it too was that
it's not like a lot of the genuine
vermeers like I said there weren't that
many of them in circulation most of the
museums that had had genuine vermeers
like obviously because of the war they
had put them in protective storage so
like the Nazis wouldn't steal them or
they wouldn't get blown up or whatever
so no one was really like looking at
vermeers every day so it's just kind of
like yeah that's a okay close enough you
know what I mean so they weren't like
they didn't have anything to like
compare it to really like right in front
of their face so it didn't have to be
[ __ ] great and it wasn't
so he bought it now
so uh so from there like uh Alois midle
he trade he passed it on to uh good old
Hermon Goring Herman Goring
now he actually ended up Goring actually
traded
137 paintings that they had looted
obviously
for this one supposed Vermeer painting
and he was so proud of that [ __ ] that he
hung it in his house you know what I
mean because he apparently thought it
was a real or didn't care that it was
wasn't real
now
uh so in 1943
Goring actually hid this whole
collection of the looted artwork
including this Han van meegering that he
thought was a Vermeer in that uh famed
Austrian salt mine yeah along with
almost 7 000 other pieces of artwork
which had been looted by the Nazis yeah
now the Allied Forces actually in May of
1945 actually entered the salt mine and
found all of that stuff and if you're
interested in there's a great [ __ ]
book you can't remember who wrote it but
it was called The Monuments Men and it
was all about that uh that whole unit
and their whole job was to like go find
all the art that the Nazis had looted
it's a great [ __ ] book it wasn't just
art down that mine either it was a bunch
of money and [ __ ] gold bullion and
everything they had a [ __ ] ton of stuff
big [ __ ] bars of gold
yeah I remember when that I remember
[ __ ] seeing all about that yeah
but what I was saying was that um you
missed it but Goring actually traded he
thought this painting was a real Vermeer
and he traded 137 of the looted
paintings for that one thinking that it
was he didn't know he was looking at
yeah and it wasn't even a good one it
wasn't even a good fake it was a good
sales pitch that you gave him and he
traded 137 real paintings for it I guess
I don't know if like the 130 I don't
know what the 137 were that he traded
yeah maybe I'm assuming they were real
maybe they weren't that valuable maybe
so you had maybe the ones that he didn't
really want yeah they were just one yeah
maybe but like I said I mean Vermeer
paintings there was like that were a hot
commodity at the time because he didn't
Premiere didn't paint that many yeah so
you know what I mean
and he was kind of like he's having a
moment
reportedly
Goring would put his toga on and he had
an art appreciation room that was all
decked out like something out of ancient
Rome
where he'd sit up there on one of those
damn Roman couches and [ __ ] drink and
shoot [ __ ] morphine did he have
somebody feed him grapes yeah evidently
he had like [ __ ] waitresses and [ __ ]
bringing him stuff and they'd bring art
out to him so he could look at it
and while they were playing photograph
[ __ ] records and [ __ ]
it's weird to me like why
Roman nope I like going to museums and
looking at artists which is the next guy
but it's just kind of like why I don't
see what's so exciting about just like
laying there having somebody drop grapes
in your mouth
just kind of a upper middle class or
middle class dude trying to be an
aristocrat you know [ __ ] Conquering
the world you know I'm [ __ ] yeah from
their point of view [ __ ] saving
Western Civilization from [ __ ] you
know deterioration and [ __ ] and [ __ ]
um whatever dudes yeah
yeah
but they didn't the you know what I mean
[ __ ] it was he was a man of his time
you know [ __ ] but it's just [ __ ]
hilarious ridiculous he was junkie
mostly you know a lot of them were they
were just ridiculous it Clowny clownish
kind of silly Nazis they were I mean
yeah and honestly it's not really lying
if you actually go into the details that
they were there wasn't much to those
dudes I mean that's what I mean and I'm
not trying I'm not being glib I'm not
trying to like minimize what they did
because obviously they did like that was
[ __ ] horrific but I think it's better
to gotta be real to mean people like
that for the [ __ ] even though the the
consequences of their stupidity and
their [ __ ]
silliness is horrible but I think it's
better it's just kind of like serial
killers I always kind of like make fun
of their dick size and stuff like that
because
I don't know just the whole thing is
like ridiculous it wasn't just them they
were in a fight between the [ __ ]
Soviets
and they were both bad and it's just it
was just part of the European scene and
they both it started off it was a
[ __ ] fight to the death between two
empires that were
[ __ ] extreme they both were and they
kind of beat each other into that shape
but the dudes that were behind it even
including Stalin and stuff if you
actually look at the details the person
Stalin was a street dog and a [ __ ]
robber basically who ended up joining a
revolutionary party he was a [ __ ]
Street assassin he was a little bitty
[ __ ] five foot three [ __ ] kind of
a nobody but he was real ruthless and
smart
um he knew how to turn people and one
against the others a group fantastic
divider
um so you know
yeah they were [ __ ] up but in time
Europe was [ __ ] up at that time they
were just
had been taken over basically by [ __ ]
gangs you know well and I kind of feel
like people like that people with that
kind of mindset that they have they
really need to be like they need to get
the [ __ ] over themselves is what they
need to do a lot of it had to do with
ideology reading too many books and
believing [ __ ]
both sides
Pie in the Sky Thinking magical thinking
uh trying to be more than what you are
there's a lot of stuff involved with
that uh
believing 100 that you're the good guy
and
but it was just but man come on let's be
honest
all of European histories kind of like
that
going all the way back to [ __ ]
ancient Rome Greece the Spartans kind of
extreme I think a lot of things would be
better if more people would just like
get the [ __ ] over themselves
I think a lot of it had to do with the
technological limitations of the time
uh things were run by [ __ ]
governments and governments are a
certain way
uh nowadays you don't need need them
like you used to I mean most of
Washington DC is just empty buildings
people pretending like they're working
[ __ ] the internet does a lot of it
the internet and [ __ ] companies are
doing doing most of it
back in the days when all that I don't
want to get I'm getting off topic go
ahead yeah no kidding it's all obsolete
it's all Obsolete and it was kind of
obsolete back then a little bit what
they were doing
so okay so this is how han van meegrin
ended up getting caught
because what happened was that when they
found the salt mine with all the
paintings in it including that van
meeger and one that Goring thought was a
Vermeer
the Allied Forces questioned the Nazi
Banker who had bought the painting in
the first place and got it into goring's
hands model
and because he had kept meticulous
records as Nazis tended to do they
actually uh the authorities actually
traced the painting back to Van meeguren
that's what the provenance of it was
so van meeger and actually got arrested
in May of 1945 and he was actually
charged not with forgery because they
thought it was a Vermeer he was charged
with fraud and also aiding and abetting
the enemy like they were essentially
like you're taking
Dutch cultural uh you know artifacts and
selling them to the Nazis
um so that's what actually they arrested
him for there was no nobody knew
anything about forgery at this point
so he gets sent to prison uh as an
alleged Nazi collaborator
um because he was again like plundering
Dutch property like cultural property
and selling it to the Nazis and they
were not happy about that uh and they
were actually going to give him the
death penalty because that's what the uh
you know that's that's what the penalty
for that was
now of he kind of like thought about
he's like well [ __ ] um kind of in a
pickle at this point uh if I say that
this is actually a Vermeer then I'm
gonna get hanged or whatever
um but if I say that I painted it then
I'm also gonna get in trouble because
that's also illegal in the end uh he's
like well I guess forgery isn't doesn't
have a death penalty so I'm just gonna
say that I painted it so he's basically
like uh what he said his quote was the
painting in goring's hands is not as you
assume a Vermeer of delft but a van
magerin I painted the picture
so they actually had to verify this for
a while and like I said the first time
that I read about this guy was in an
article called he paints for his life
and it it leaned very hard into the hole
they made him paint
of painting like in the courtroom like
while everybody was looking which they
did because they were kind of like they
were trying to prove that he actually uh
could paint it any and he did paint one
now he actually painted his last forgery
uh in the courtroom
with everybody watching like over a few
months period and it was called Jesus
among the doctors or sometimes called
young Christ in the temple and it was
like a Vermeer style painting and he's
just like see I can paint like Vermeer
and they were like oh okay I suppose so
um so basically
here's the thing so not only did he
paint the painting in the courtroom like
to show everybody that he had actually
done it and could actually do it
um he also kind of spun a little bit of
a narrative
once he got caught that
uh yeah I [ __ ] over the Nazis and I'm
also by the way a super Dutch Patriot
because I got Goring to give me back 137
Dutch paintings for this one fake one
he's spinning a [ __ ] so yeah but
that's how we played it yeah and
everybody was just kind of like all
right yeah he's a hero yeah well that's
a good way
I mean what else could he have done what
else could he do it works propaganda
worked the judge didn't like buy it at
first he was just kind of like um you
guys see how you're spinning it he said
uh the judge says to him at one point
you do admit though that you sold these
pictures for very high prices van
meekeren said I could hardly have done
otherwise had I sold them for low prices
it would have been obvious they were
fake yeah and I was just like yeah
that's a good answer okay I got you
um he countered it yeah so that's what
I'm saying but he did very much and I
think it was very successful like the
way that they spun it like where you
know he said hey I got Goring to
give me 137 paintings which maybe would
have been lost right yeah if you know
and I'm saving like Dutch cultural
you're right right so he tried to kind
of like play it like that and I kind of
feel like
that narrative kind of like survived a
little bit until probably recent times
because it's only like what a com man
does yeah you got it all planned out or
what you're gonna say and everything
[ __ ] with the good PR yeah okay the
thing about it though is that um
so even though like I said he kind of
gets played as like you know a national
hero
for pulling a fast one on the Nazis uh
there were a couple of little
complicating factors
1945 while van meegren was still in
prison
um a very maybe like uh
uh uncut uncomfortable item turned up in
Hitler's private Library when they were
going through it it was apparently this
uh volume of poems by a Dutch Nazi poet
this book had been illustrated by Han
van meeguren okay and had an inscription
in it that said to my beloved fuhrer in
grateful tribute from H van meeguran
Lauren North Holland 1942. yeah
so there's that now so they asked him
about this and he said oh well that's my
signature but I didn't write the rest of
that [ __ ] somebody else must have
written that even though it was all the
same handwriting and they're just like
you're dealing with a businessman yeah
he's just trying to like squirm his way
out of stuff you dealing with a
businessman he's trying to make money
where the money is also he didn't really
seem to have any compunction about like
you know obviously when Jewish families
around him were like rounded up and
taken away like he bought up all their
property like ooh cashing in and yeah
and it was like what can I do I can't
stop it that's what I thought and I'm
sure that's how he adjusted and like
it's just gonna sit there and it's gonna
go to these Nazis so if I'd get it then
I'll save it that's exactly that's how
you I kind of feel like that yeah I kind
of feel like that's how he's old yeah I
mean his family said he was like a
lovely person but
I don't know throughout his life I kind
of get the feeling that he was more like
a Nazi sympathizer kind of person yeah I
think he was born like an opportunist
yeah he's just like I don't give a [ __ ]
I just want like he would have said he
would have cited who was who with
whoever was in power and here's the
thing is that a lot of people are like
that I think that a lot of people are
like that whoever's in power that you
side with because that's where the money
is
he was just one of those
I mean he just I mean like I said he
made a lot of money doing that and he
just wanted to preserve that like as
much as possible
so you know what I mean so he didn't
really give a [ __ ] if he [ __ ] other
people over or anything like that so he
was just I don't know like like I said
no he's gonna be like not evil but just
selfish I can't stop this right
make my money right is what I do so so
after he um you know painted the Vermeer
in the courtroom and everybody said okay
well obviously that Vermeer is like you
know you painted it and it was fake so
whatever
and after he spun this whole narrative
him a hero because I saved all these
paintings so when he came out the
courtroom like they had like a whole
like all his fans out there like
cheering for him and everything like
that
um because obviously um you know
collaborating with the Nazis he would
have got the death penalty but because
it went to like the Lesser forgery
charge he actually only ended up getting
sentenced to a year in prison I don't
even think he served that
um now he did have to Forfeit his wealth
because he had gotten it illegally
but
um remember how earlier I said that he
divorced his wife legally and like put a
bunch of [ __ ] in her name that's why he
did this so they took a lot of his [ __ ]
away but 50 million dollars was still in
her name
playing up to retire wrong so well yeah
but the thing about it
was that he dropped dead only two years
you know he wasn't always two years
later
his wife Johanna lived until she was 91.
yeah in very in style because she had
all that [ __ ] money she had all that
[ __ ] money he didn't know that was
gonna happen well no but I'm just saying
yeah now he actually still like painted
and stuff like after he got released
from prison and he signed his works with
his own name and because he was famous
now like now he could sell his own
paintings like with his own name on them
and like people would buy them because
it's like hey you're the guy that like
[ __ ] over the Nazis so um yeah so his
painting sold for a lot more than they
would have like before he got outed as a
forger
um they did an opinion poll in the
Netherlands in 1947 and Han van meegren
was the second most popular person in
the nation after the prime minister so
there's that uh so like I said but that
was kind of predicated on the narrative
that he was a hero which like I said
it's not really
not really what happened he that's just
kind of how he sold it
um but he did kind of like cry about a
little bit though like his whole thing
uh at his trial he said my Triumph is a
counterfeiter was my defeat as a
creative artist which I was like well
you chose your path man I mean you made
a lot of money now after he got released
or sentenced or released I don't know if
like I said if he even served a year but
he actually died only a couple months
after he got out uh he died of heart
failure which they think was maybe a
complication of uh syphilis because like
I said he was kind of a manhorn uh he
was 58 years old relatively young
actually he was 58 yeah yeah that's not
that old nope so that's what happened at
58 was old then though yeah I guess but
like I said his wife lived till she was
91. yeah with all that money well women
always lived a long time
yeah women live long term yeah usually
yeah we do live longer well I mean on
average they do a little longer
um so one of the recent books about van
meager and this like I said and I think
I kind of like touched on this earlier
but particularly in regards to uh the
separate Emmaus which was kind of like
his best forgery like the first big like
perfect forgery that he did
um this kind of this book like brings up
the question like how could anybody have
been fooled by this because like I said
it's not good like even if you've seen a
handful of vermeer's actual works seeing
this painting you're just kind of like
it's just it's not it it's just not it
like it's similar but it it very clearly
looks like a fake at least to me I don't
really know like it looks like a fake
it's not even the same
thing but like you said I kind of feel
like
I feel I feel like there was kind of a
thing going on the period Vermeer was
very much a hot commodity at the time he
didn't have that many known Works people
were looking to oh he must have painted
more than 35 paintings in his hole
because he lived a long time so there
must be more out there someplace
um so the market was primed for it and I
think too that the first one that he did
was good enough that everybody was like
yeah probably like they did all the
chemical tests on it they're like okay
that seems like a you know a real one
and then like as he started putting them
out and they just weren't that good
anymore and people were still falling
for it she's like [ __ ] man I don't even
have to put any effort into this crap
anymore because they'll just like take
any old [ __ ] that I crap out and because
I think at some point with the girls
high well that's it yeah well I think at
some point with the critics and with the
people that were by like the collectors
that were buying it I think at some
point they they got into like the sunk
cost fallacy where they're just kind of
like well I've I'm already all in on
this and if I go back now and say hey
these are all fake I'm gonna look like a
tool so they don't really want to do
that got a situation where there's fakes
in there that are accepted as real and
they say well this one looks like that
one and we are accepting that one as a
real so this must right
but no yeah I think it was just if you
looked at them all at the same time
you'd probably clearly delineate you
could see that there's a difference I
mean if I showed you and you probably
you don't know anything about it because
I actually do know a lot about Vermeer
about like Dutch art of this time period
um if I showed you like us a handful of
real vermeers and then I showed you a
picture of this guy's thing you would I
think you would immediately be able to
pick out the one that was fake yeah I
think
um you know I I don't know but maybe we
should do that experiment because
I could I'm sure I can tell because I I
think you can tell handwriting I think
you could probably tell you're right I
mean I I just kind of feel like there's
a bit you can see the difference in
what's called Gestalt yeah between I
think you'd be able to tell so good no
it's not the same like I said van Meeker
and it wasn't dumb and he was just kind
of like he did model
his Vermeer like uh separate Emmaus
after a Caravaggio one because he
posited that Vermeer had gone to Italy
and studied the Caravaggio one
Caravaggio is another guy that we need
to do a show about that that
[ __ ] like murdered a dude he was
a fascinating character also but um I
wrote I actually wrote like a like an
illustrated novel and the hurricane
hasn't hit us yet
well I said it's going to be morning
it's not it's the Eyes
heavy winds by now we had a little bit
earlier like I heard it earlier but I
don't hear anything like right now which
is good because like the power stayed on
so we're pretty much done well hold on a
second hold on like I gotta just like a
couple hours I cook too okay okay yeah
but yeah so like I said I'll I'll show
you the paintings and I'll see if you
could I bet you don't because there's I
to me there's like a big difference but
I don't know if that's just because I
know a lot about that time period
um but so uh so yeah so basically they
did
um in 1967 like a few years after they
did uh Carnegie Mellon University in
Pittsburgh they had a bunch of vermeers
in their collection and they were kind
of like nervous about it so they're like
maybe we should do like some chemical
[ __ ] tests on this now and they
confirmed that several of their
paintings were in fact probably fakes uh
created in the 20th century and they
concluded that a lot of the vermeers
that they had were possibly van maker
and forgeries uh the thing that mostly
include them in was the white lead uh
Vermeer did use white lead painting like
uh paint for his white but the chemical
composition of it uh where the lead came
from back in vermeer's time is different
to where the lead comes from nowadays so
that's usually even if you can get
everything else right you can't get
white lead from that time period anymore
because the lead doesn't come from the
place that it came from back then so
that's kind of like uh one of the main
things that they use to determine like
that the [ __ ] is not from back then they
did some other scientific tests in 1977
on these same vermeers and came to the
same conclusion that they were fakes
interestingly and maybe a little bit
ironically
van meegren's own work Rose in price
after he became known as a forger as I
said uh and consequently came worth
became worthwhile to fake his paintings
so now we actually have it's like an
oroboros of art forgery where it's just
kind of like now we're forging the
forger's paintings because his paintings
are getting well known so now people are
forging his so uh so some people have
taken paintings that kind of look
vermeeri or look kind of like uh you
know Old Dutch Masters but not really
that good and then we'll sign Han van
meegren's name on it and like try to
pass it off as him and like sell it as
that so that's pretty funny and like
some people are doing some fakes like
nude paintings in his style as well
um and they actually started doing that
when he was alive interestingly too he
also had a son named Jacques van
meeguren and he started faking his dad's
work too like he would do paintings in
his dad's style they weren't as good and
he would uh put his dad's like signature
on them to try to pass them off as his
it's like I don't know why that was like
so funny to me but it's like he's spent
his whole life like Fortune other
people's [ __ ] and now people are forging
his [ __ ] too uh also gotta say just the
last thing
2019 there was a movie that came out
called the last Vermeer and this was
actually based on the 2008 book the man
who made vermeers which is by Jonathan
Lopez and actually Guy Pierce is in it
uh so actually I kind of want to see
that now I didn't read that book but I
did read another one about Han van
meegroom which also came out in 2008
which is really really good it's called
the forger's spell a true story of
Vermeer Nazis and the greatest art hopes
of the 20th century that was written by
Edward dolnick so I actually like really
do recommend that I've heard that the
man who made vermeer's uh by Jose
Jonathan Lopez is also good as well but
I haven't read that one yet but if
you're interested in this guy like
seriously like check out some of the
books and I want to see this movie too
like the last Premiere because that
sounds like really interesting as well
so yeah I think that's we've wrapped it
up right okay we have to wrap it up all
right American Military 100 said it's
asking if we're in the path of the
hurricane yeah we are we're dead set we
are um yeah we're hopefully yeah it made
landfall about four hours south of here
on the coast
and so I'm kind of hoping that by the
time it gets here that what it will have
weakened some yeah well I know it will
it'll be about 70 mile an hour it may be
80 mile an hour winds which is bad but
not that's not bad when it made landfall
it was like 155. and like I said Naples
is [ __ ] flooding what did we say
around eight o'clock in the morning
I think it's yeah it's gonna be tonight
like we got like a little bit of a band
like earlier like I heard it like
blowing outside yeah but five o'clock in
the morning we'll probably hear high
winds I would imagine yeah so uh look
let me go down there and start working
on these damn pizzas
because I got to get rid of the uh the
fresh mushrooms oh it's a mushroom pizza
you don't want any meat I got oh no I
don't know okay all right you know you
know how I feel about people divide it
up I just I want mushrooms and that's it
okay go ahead and I'll go get that all
right so hopefully everybody enjoyed the
show I'm really glad we kept the power
on the whole time like the weather held
and I'm happy about it hopefully
we'll let you guys know like what's
going on hopefully we'll be back up
Friday night like hopefully the power
won't go out for days and days because
that would really suck we do have
generators but I don't really know how
it's gonna go but yeah we haven't really
had the worst of the [ __ ] hit us yet
it's supposed to like hit overnight but
I'm hoping that it'll weaken by the time
it gets to us because we're about
I said earlier but we're about 30-ish
miles like north of Orlando so we're
still in the cone but the eye hasn't got
here yet I think the eye is supposed to
be over Orlando tomorrow morning at
eight in the morning so we'll see how it
goes
hmm I'm just I'm hoping everything will
be okay and it'll all work out uh Tammy
says great show Jenny you two stay safe
and hopefully see you on Friday thank
you very much yeah this was a a topic
that I've been wanting to do for a long
time because I was I don't know why I
just find this guy like really
fascinating so I'm glad that I finally
got to do a show about him Danny Rowling
said awesome show tonight thank you very
much hopefully we'll be back on Friday
evening I'll keep you guys apprised of
what's going on with the situation down
here hopefully everything works out okay
but thanks for dropping by and thanks
for hanging out with us on this
Wednesday evening we will see you guys
hopefully again on Friday night good
night